hello everyone welcome to the may 2022
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
things have been a little hectic around
here at mindscape world international
headquarters uh
writing some science papers giving some
talks preparing to move from los angeles
to baltimore which is a big deal and uh
of course working on the copy editing
and proofreading for the book the
biggest ideas in the universe
volume one space time in motion it's
supposed to be out in september a lot of
copy editing a lot of making sure the
figures look right and stuff like that
but anyway it's all refreshingly normal
kind of stuff so i'm not gonna dwell on
it tell any stories anything like that
let's just remind everyone that the amas
the ask me anything episodes are brought
to you by supporters on patreon you can
become such a supporter yourself by
going to patreon.com
sean m carroll patreon supporters pay
for nice things like the transcripts for
all the episodes and they help with the
sound quality a little bit in some ways
and by being a patreon supporter you get
ad-free versions of every podcast plus
the ability to ask questions at these
amas as well as the usual warm fuzzy
feeling for doing a nice thing and being
part of something bigger than ourselves
that's it let's go
[Music]
dave lejudice says do you think our
current electromagnetic sensing
abilities rule out local alien visitors
i'm surprised at the near zero credence
given to the possibility that aliens are
in our solar system in fermi paradox
discussions
well no i mean as the as you asked the
question the answer is no i do not think
our current sensing abilities rule out
local alien visitors it would be
completely trivial for aliens
with very very high technological
abilities to be in the solar system
without giving off a signal that we
could notice all they have to do is hide
on the far side of the moon and then it
would be very difficult to notice them
but certainly if they hit out on pluto
it would be even easier but i also don't
really think that's the issue and this
is the kind of
backwards pseudo-bayesianism that gets
you in trouble when we think about
things like aliens the question being
asked is you know can you think of a way
can we cook up a scenario in which there
are aliens there but we haven't noticed
them sure that's easy to do it's not
that difficult to imagine but it's also
not the question we should be asking the
question we should be asking is
in the two different hypotheses one of
which there are aliens here in the solar
system and the other which there aren't
what do you expect
what are the predictions the
expectations the likelihoods in the
technical bayesian jargon
under each one of those hypotheses and
then we compare that to the data and the
point is if there's no aliens in the
solar system we expect exactly what we
see namely no evidence for aliens if
there are
aliens out there why would they be
hiding right under the vast majority of
versions of aliens in the solar system i
could think of they would be easy to
find and therefore the fact that we
don't have any evidence for them is
strong evidence against their existing
it's never 100 so maybe they're out
there but given that it would be very
very easy to notice them under the vast
majority of circumstances that we can
imagine the absence of such evidence is
strong reason to decrease whatever prior
you have if you're prior that there are
aliens in the solar system is 0.99999
it won't matter you'll still think that
but that's the slippery problem of uh
being a principal bayesian when you try
to pick your priors in a good way
igor parshkin says can you convince me
to vote i've never voted my life because
i know that i don't know enough about
what's going on behind the curtains to
make an informed decision anyone who
just reads the news gets biased opinions
that do not reflect everything that's
going on also if say i lean left and you
sit me down with a smart politician from
the right and i'm open-minded enough i'm
100 sure they can change my opinion so
how can i vote based on my values when i
know that there are definitely things
i'm overlooking and things i can't
possibly know because they're happening
on the inside so this is an interesting
question because the usual question can
you convince me to vote is more about
the unlikelihood that any one vote would
matter we talked about this with herb
gintus right
when you talk about elections with
enough people voting the probability
that any one person's vote is going to
be the deciding factor is so incredibly
tiny that it might as well not matter at
all but igor's question's a little bit
different he's saying i just don't know
enough to vote right and therefore maybe
i shouldn't and you know honestly i'm
not going to try to convince you to vote
i think it's okay if you don't vote and
we talked to andrew lee who is a working
politician in australia where they have
mandatory voting and he thinks it's a
good system and you know he thinks that
because people are supposed to vote in
that country they actually pay closer
attention to the media
um but
if you don't i'm of the opinion if you
don't want to vote that's okay i do wish
that more people would vote so i think
it's a legitimate question can i vince
you to do it and but i don't know really
what to say to the question except i
don't buy the argument i i don't buy the
argument that you can't get
good information uh in the news media at
all you can get bad information from the
news media that's perfectly true but
also there's good information out there
and i think it's a little bit of an
abdication of abdication of
responsibility to just shrug your
shoulders and say well who knows what's
going on i think we have to develop our
skill set of being able to distinguish
between good information and bad
information um if you're 100 sure that
talking to someone on the other side can
change your opinion that's you know in
some sense good for you but in another
sense it means that you need to do that
talking to both sides and figure out
which side you agree with more um i hope
it's not the case that if you talk to
two people on different sides
alternating
a hundred times in a row that you would
change your mind a hundred times that
would be well at least it would be very
strange i don't think most people are
like that i think that most of us have
values we get information and
not only are there factual matters about
you know what a certain policy is etc
but there's also value alignment right
there's there's the idea that certain
political figures are just talking the
talk that resonates with how you want
things to be the reason why
we vote for people rather than do direct
democracy and vote on every single uh
bill or issue coming up it's because we
aren't supposed to be experts we're
supposed to vote for people who
i mean ideally they would be experts but
in the real world things are so
complicated that they hire staff members
who are experts themselves but the point
is you vote for people who will
represent your values who if they care
about the environment if you care about
the environment you can vote for someone
who clearly cares about the environment
if you care about gun rights you can
vote for someone who cares about gun
rights
and all those different ways of going
down the line of course there will be
misinformation and people will lie about
things but you know they have a record
for voting right you can see what they
actually vote for and against uh if
you're really interested if you don't
care that's one thing okay but if you're
interested but you don't think that you
have enough information i'm just not
skeptical that that's true because i
think there's a lot of information out
there a lot of it is pretty objective
right you can choose to get information
from biased sources but a lot of
information is is actually pretty
reliable like some where someone voted
on some bill just you know look up in
the congressional record or whatever i
think that's pretty reliable um there's
a lot of re news sources out there who
are perfectly reliable no one's
perfectly reliable but quite reliable
and who are never less denigrated
because by one side or the other because
they don't like what they're saying but
that's you know something we have to
learn to to get beyond so i don't have
any specific uh either
advice or arguments to convince you but
i do
will i will put forward the opinion that
we all have values and we all have a
responsibility to figure out what we
think is true about the world and that's
the stuff on the basis of which we vote
it's not an easy thing by any means but
that's what i think that we're supposed
to try to do kevin o'toole says
i really enjoyed your book from eternity
to here one question though is still
bothering me in the first two chapters
you describe time asymmetry from two
different perspectives there's a physics
based asymmetry where entropy was low in
the past and will be high in the future
there's also a cause and effect
asymmetry where from the perspectives of
people and other agents of change an
agent's action cannot change the past
but can change the future
it seemed like the point there was to
say that one asymmetry implied the other
but unfortunately i just don't see any
good reason why the two asymmetries
should be related at all is there some
fundamental contradiction either
intuitive or in the math in imagining a
time reversed agent who remembers the
high entropy future and whose actions
change the high entropy past uh yes
there is a fundamental contradiction in
that and it's kind of too long of a of a
story to tell you right here in the ama
i will point to the fact that i just
gave a talk on this
at berkeley which is going to be
mentioned in the very next question but
in a different context so the title the
talk was the arrow of time in causal
networks it's on youtube you can find it
where i talk about exactly this i talk
about the connection between the
increase of entropy and the causal arrow
the fact that causes precede effects now
there's a footnote there's many
footnotes there different people have
different ideas about what you mean by
cause and effect so you can have a
certain construal of the idea of a cause
by which causes and effects for
simultaneous et cetera et cetera et
cetera so forget about all of those
details i mean the usual thing
i mean that if i swing my arm and knock
over a glass of wine i say the glass
fell down because i swung my arm i do
not say i swung my arm because the glass
was going to fall okay
that's explicable because entropy has
been increasing the entropic arrow of
time the fact that entropy was low in
the past and is increasing toward the
future
that in my view is the single fact
underlying all of the asymmetries
between past and future and our
macroscopic universe so what is the
connection you know very very briefly
if you didn't have entropy at all
if you were laplace's demon you know
exactly the microstate of the universe
right
then there's no such thing as cause and
effect and there's no such thing as an
arrow of time there's just the state of
the universe at every moment
and it exactly implies the state of the
previous moment and the next moment in a
deterministic universe we can also argue
about determinism but that's again
another
kettle of fish to talk about um but in
the deterministic
assumption like the schrodinger equation
or newton's laws of motion uh every
moment has all the information that
implies all the previous moments and all
the next moments so
just by construction the existence of
something like an arrow of time and
including
causes preceding effects must come about
because somehow you coarse grain right
because you're not laplace's demon if
you know the exact microstate of the
world then you predict both the future
and the past with perfect fidelity and
doesn't make sense to talk about causes
and effects
the information contained in the
universe at every moment of time fixes
every other moment in this deterministic
model so you can't pinpoint whether
something is a cause happening first or
in fact happening after okay
but we don't have that information we
are not laplace's demon we have very
incomplete information about the
universe uh we coarse grain we look at
the universe and we notice some
observationally accessible features of
it and there's other microscopic
features that we do not notice and so
what i argued in my
talk in berkeley is that you can
actually
use this fact in the context of what are
called causal networks this is
a way of thinking about cause and effect
relationships that is very very popular
in both computer science artificial
intelligence right now but also all over
the social sciences a way of stringing
together different facts about the
universe which they will call random
variables because they're facts with
certain probabilities attached to them
drawing lines between them and making a
little network and then saying okay
where are the causes and where are the
effects and there's certain features of
where you can draw those arrows
connecting the different random
variables the different features of the
universe like i'm swinging my arm the
glass is falling down so that means
there's a certain probability that i
swing my arm a certain probability the
glass falls down and a mutual
relationship between them right
conditional probabilities and so forth
and all of that can be used to talk
about causes and effects if you also add
in
some counterfactual information if i
consider what happens if i hadn't swung
my arm would the glass have still fallen
down right that's where you can get a
true handle on causality and so the
thing is that
you can do that going forward in time
you can draw arrows from past features
of the universe to future features of
the universe purely based on the
macroscopically available information
that's what we do all the time we
predict the future probabilistically not
deterministically because we don't have
all the information but we predict
what's going to happen in the future on
the basis of the present state of the
universe this is a feature of physics is
that you don't need to also know the
past you might need to know certain
relics of the past that are embedded in
the current moment but the point is you
only need to know the current moment
okay this is called the markovian
property in computer science and
statistics and elsewhere in random
processes generally markovianness is the
fact that you can predict what happens
next just on the basis of the current
moment and so you can make a causal
diagram going from events to other
events forward in time that is to say
from the big bang to today and toward
the future but the point is you can't do
it backwards you cannot make a causal
diagram with the arrows pointing in the
other way and the reason is because
when you go backward in time the current
state of the universe is not enough to
predict the past state of the universe
you also need to assume a low entropy
past that's what's called the past
hypothesis
otherwise if that were not true
then the kinds of reconstructions we do
of the past and the future would be the
same right we'd have the same access to
things about the future and things about
the past from the present but we don't
we have things like memories and records
and fossils and photographs right we
have information about the past why
because there's an extra thing going on
namely that the universe started with a
low entropy past that gives us extra
information about the past that we don't
have about the future but we need to
assume that low entropy passed to really
make that information be reliable so
therefore the evolution from today to
yesterday
is not markovian
it's not you know today and therefore
you can retrodict yesterday it's that
you know today and you know the big bang
you know the very very low entropy past
those two facts are enough to
reconstruct what it is possible to
reconstruct about the past okay so
anyway the very short answer here which
i'm
not necessarily sure is going to make
sense if you're not already familiar
with this jargon but i'm trying to give
you the very short version of the
argument you can make a causal diagram
with arrows moving toward the future if
entropy is increasing but you cannot do
it if enter if
with the enter with the arrows going to
the past if entropy was lower in the
past because it there's an extra fact
that you need
and now you can argue whether or not the
notion of
causality in these causal networks is
the right one the notion basically is
that if i were able to keep everything
else in the universe fixed but change
one fact
change whether i swing my arm does that
have effects downstream
so the glass is being knocked over the
glass is not being knocked over the the
classic example is you notice a
correlation in the data that if people
are outside and it's sunny they do not
have umbrellas up if people are outside
and it's raining they do have an
umbrellas up so in the data
you don't know whether rain causes
umbrellas to go up or putting umbrellas
up causes rain right there's just a
correlation between them so you need
this
information that is not in the data this
counterfactual information if you could
imagine putting a person there raising
their umbrella would it start raining no
if you imagine it raining and there's
someone who didn't have their umbrella
up would they raise their umbrella yes
so that's the direction in which the
causality goes and that's a story you
can tell forward in time because entropy
is increasing it's not a story you can
tell backward in time
related question comes from liam mccarty
who says in your recent lecture at
berkeley the arrow of time in causal
networks and then he gives the youtube
address if you want to check it out in
the comments
you mentioned that the smoothness of the
cosmic microwave background is dependent
on the past hypothesis that is without
stipulating that the early universe was
low entropy we couldn't say that the
cosmic microwave background is smooth
this is a fascinating point i hadn't
heard before but i'm still struggling to
understand exactly what you meant can
you discuss this here yeah this is a
very very important point because it's
part of
recognizing that how we reason about the
world physics and other things is always
sort of assumes the past hypothesis even
before we knew what it was or you knew
there was such a thing as entropy we
assume the arrow of time i think is
probably a better way of saying it so we
put a telescope like wmap or plonk out
there in the sky or we do observations
here on the ground or in balloons etc we
map the cosmic microwave background we
find that this leftover radiation from
the big bang is pretty smooth it looks
more or less the same in different
directions but not exactly there are
small fluctuations one part and ten to
the five okay
and we say look therefore
the early universe the moment from which
this radiation was emitted which is only
like three hundred thousand years after
the big bang
the physical world was smooth right
that's why the radiation that we're
seeing now looks smooth because the
actual primordial plasma was smooth more
or less the same density and temperature
at different points in time at different
places sorry throughout the universe
but that's not what we see
we don't see the primordial plasma what
we see is
photons microwave photons landing in our
telescope here on earth we see the
radiation field locally right next to
our telescope that's what we actually
see
we use
our brains to reconstruct what the early
universe must have looked like based on
that radiation field impacting our
telescope here and now
but of course when we do that we're
assuming that entropy has been
increasing along the way so think about
it the photons that come to us from the
microwave background
the their wavelengths depend on many
different things their wavelengths
depend on what the temperature was at
the cosmic microwave background but it
also depends on the velocity of the
fluid right there's a doppler effect
going back and forth and it also depends
on the gravitational field that is going
around because there's a gravitational
redshift that can blue
redshift or blue shift uh depending on
how the gravitational field goes it can
change the frequency of that photon okay
so if you just ask the question
given the photons that we see here in
our telescope but we make no assumption
about the low entropy of the big bang we
allow it to be super duper high entropy
and you say in all the different ways
that we could have gotten that image
that we get in our telescopes what does
a typical
reconstruction of the early universe
look like and the answer is it is wildly
inhomogeneous there's very different
densities and temperatures and
velocities and gravitational fields from
place to place
but
they have all conspired exactly to
cancel out so that we see a very smooth
radiation field in our telescope today
and if you ask yourself well if you
think to yourself
that seems very unlikely
why in the world
would there be some massive conspiracy
where all these very different effects
exactly cancel out or almost exactly
cancel out to give us an isotropic
smooth cosmic microwave background well
there's no good reason for them to do
that but that's not the question we
asked we asked the question
conditionalized on the fact that we have
a smooth image in our telescope and no
other fact
what is the likelihood that
the early universe looked one way or
another so without the past hypothesis
the early universe is overwhelmingly
likely to be very very very high entropy
right because you didn't make it be low
entropy and there's more ways to be high
entropy than low entropy
it is unlikely
given that high entropy state that we
would see a smooth cmb today
but it's less unlikely than that there
really was a low entropy state in the
early universe just by accident
so if you don't have the past hypothesis
you have to imagine that with
overwhelming likelihood the smoothness
of the cmb is just a conspiracy it's
just an accident it is a downward
fluctuation in entropy because without
the past hypothesis we right now are at
the minimum moment of entropy in the
history of the universe it would be
higher in both the past and the future
now no one believes that's true there's
zero reason it just doesn't make sense
to think that that's true uh the actual
universe was low entropy is the right
way to think and therefore you can use
ordinary scientific reconstruction to
understand that the pictures we take in
our telescope really are evidence that
the early universe was smooth but it's
only evidence because we can and do and
should assume the past hypothesis of low
entropy
okay mr fu says looking back 500 years
in the past and how we managed to
disprove so many scientists of that era
do you think that 500 years in the
future all of our understandings of
quantum mechanics and mathematics could
be proven completely wrong by scientists
of the future which might in a which
might in case invalidate many worlds and
other important concepts
well you know i think it's actually
there's two things going on one is that
uh by picking 500 years in the past
you've gone a little bit further than
the scientific revolution so there
weren't scientists back in that era okay
once we had the scientific revolution
once we had people like galileo and
copernicus and kepler and and descartes
and newton and so forth and hook and
whatever uh
they said a lot of things that are true
that we still think are true today right
now they're not fundamental truths
newtonian mechanics is not fundamentally
true it's been superseded by quantum
mechanics and relativity but there is
still a limit in which it's a very very
good description of what happens there
are situations in which it is correct
you don't need to know general
relativity to fly a rocket to the moon
newtonian mechanics and gravity works
perfectly well
uh that's what i expect will be the case
going forward sometimes we have ideas in
science even
post-scientific revolution that turn out
to be wrong that's absolutely true you
know the plum pudding model of the atom
is everyone's favorite uh example but
you know the plum pudding model of the
atom was never something everyone
believed it was just an idea out there
that we knew perfectly well we weren't
certain about or even very very high
credence
so i think that the thing is that uh the
something like quantum mechanics
something like general relativity even
the standard model of particle physics
the core theory if you like these are
really accurate effective theories and
they're not going to go away they might
be replaced by better theories but there
will still be a regime a domain in which
they work perfectly well
whether or not many worlds is going to
survive or not i have no idea you know i
mean i have a i have a credence i think
it will survive but i could be wrong
about that
eric speckard says
you've mentioned several times that
human constructivism lets you be judgy
can you elaborate on what you mean by
that if moral beliefs are contingent and
specific to an individual as i
understand the case to be in human
constructivism in what sense can you be
justified in being judgey uh so i think
all the work here is is in being done by
the word justified in that last sentence
so for those of you who don't know i
talk about human constructivism in the
big picture and elsewhere uh it's a view
of morality where you say that there is
no
once and for all universal rational way
to be moral what there are are
individual ways of deciding what you
think is moral and then in the world you
get out there and talk to other people
and try to work with them the best you
can given that you don't necessarily
agree
on how morality works and as i like to
point out that is what actually happens
so that is how the world actually works
so if your objection to this view is
well if that were true it would just be
chaos and calamity and nothing would
work it's just the world i'm just
describing what actually happens in the
world
so i'd like to
talk about constructivism as opposed to
relativism because moral relativism as i
understand it and everyone has slightly
different definitions of these words so
i'm not that interested in debating the
definitions but
moral relativism posits that uh morality
is uh inheres in a community or a set of
individuals and is only relevant to that
community and those individuals okay but
i didn't say any of those words when i
just described human constructivism i
construct a moral theory and i think my
moral theory is the right one for me
it's the one i constructed but i'm
definitely going to use it to judge
other people's behavior right that's one
of the things you do with a good moral
theory the the crucial thing like i said
in your in the in the end of the
question is can you be justified in
doing that
and i'll say i think that this hope is a
relic of the days when we were all moral
realists moral universalists most people
still are but
back in the days when we thought that
there was a morality out there in the
sky or whatever or that we could just
perceive by pure reason or whatever we
had a justification that was universal
that was objective that you could just
logically tell people you know either
god says this or emmanuel kant says this
or whatever the golden rule says this
and then that's the way to move forward
but i think that was a mistake i think
that thinking that that's the kind of
justification that morality needs it was
just a mistake from the start it's sort
of antiquated these days
so what do you mean by being justified i
think that you know when i say like for
example men and women should have equal
rights okay
this is my judgment i do not think that
this is a
universal truth because i don't think
there are any moral universal truths but
i will also judge someone harshly if
they um
discriminate against men or women in any
uh very obvious way
and
they
will say well no my morality is
different okay
and
what i can do is judge them what i can't
do is use logic to convince them that
they're wrong
what i can do is try to
use their own views to convince them
that they're wrong like are you sure you
believe that is it really consistent
with other things you believe knowing
you know things that maybe you didn't
know about men and women and their
status in the world maybe you'll change
your mind like i can do the things
people actually do when they're trying
to make a moral case to a different
person but there's no absolute ground to
stand on to say that they're making a
mistake right like if they say two plus
two is five in ordinary arithmetic
that's a mistake if they say men and
women are do not deserve equal rights
that's not that kind of mistake
i'm still going to judge them for it
it's just not going to stop me and i'm
happy to admit i don't have that
objective justification that i might
have had if i could appeal to god or
reason or anything like that okay i'm
going to group two questions together
joshua hillerup says what do you think
about having a uni a university having a
rule that a certain percentage of
professor slots have to be
cross-disciplined
with two or more departments having to
work together to do the hiring obviously
there's lots of details that could make
specific setups bad but what is your
opinion on the general idea and then
tomer huckawin says
how would you design your dream
university or research institute given
the budget of a big university like
harvard or yale what sort of professors
would you hire on what subjects would
you focus what would the curriculum look
like etc so tomer's question is too big
for the afa but some of it will be
addressed by trying to answer joshua's
question i don't really have a grand
design
for
university slash research institute
because you know
there is no such thing as my dream
university or research institute i'm
i actually think that if anything the
problem with the set of universities and
research institutes that we have is
they're too much alike they have more or
less the same model rather than trying
to experiment and do different things
focusing on different things uh they're
pretty homogeneous they have like the
same way of doing things and if you
think that's the perfect way of doing
things that's fine but we don't know
what the perfect way of doing things is
and you know in fact i i'm leaving
caltech but i have huge admiration for
caltech for being different than other
places that doesn't make it right for
everybody i'm very very happy to tell
prospective undergraduates caltech is
not right for some people as great a
place as it is for some people it's the
perfect place for many people it's a
terrible place and i think that a lot of
people places should be like that right
i think a lot of places should uh have a
little bit of personality and be a
little bit different so i don't have a
dream university or research institute
also research institutes are very
different than universities i mean
universities are weird things trying to
combine
research and teaching in the way that
they do it's a 500 year old model in
some sense or a thousand euro i don't
know when it goes back it goes back
quite a ways 1200s maybe 800 year old
model um when research was a different
thing
than it is now as was teaching
um
and i wonder if you know how long the
perfect the model that we have right now
will actually last
um but having said all that with all
those caveats in mind
you know i'm a huge fan of the
traditional arts and sciences curriculum
i like that uh history and english and
physics and biology you know as a
astronomy major at villanova i had to
take a huge number of astronomy and
physics and math courses
and because it was a university with
very very broad
distribution requirements i had to take
a lot of humanities and social sciences
also i didn't take any biology and
chemistry
maybe i should have i don't know maybe
it shows up in the podcast i'm doing
right now but um i think
it deserves careful thought
uh this question so when i'm not
answering it i'm not
not answering it because it's not a good
question because it's a huge question uh
how to make different kinds of research
universities and institutes that would
optimize across a whole bunch of
different things you know many that are
very good at teaching some that are good
at you know science some of the
humanities uh some that are four years
some that are eight years some that are
two years you know some that are all
people living on campus some that are
you know people not living on campus and
a whole bunch of different ways to sort
of be have a personality and be a
university anyway i didn't answer your
question but i rambled on about it
joshua's question's a little bit more
focused um on the idea that universities
should have a certain percentage of
faculty that are specifically
cross-disciplined i i do like something
like that i'm not sure if that's exactly
the way to do it
you know in my as i just said in the in
the universe that i would like to have
where there's many different kinds of
universities i would love to see some
universities without any departments at
all right uh where faculty could just do
the research they wanted to do students
could in consultation with faculty
design their own courses of study
people could be hired and promoted via
ad hoc committees with different kinds
of people
so that the question of you know if you
want to hire an economic historian do
they belong in the history department or
the economics department that's a
terrible question that should never come
up you know that's a huge failure mode
of universities um and the way that it
happens is you know if you're super good
if you're a very productive uh senior
level person
you can be interdisciplinary right you
can get your own grants you can find
your own little institute bring get your
own
group together and whatever there's
plenty of interdisciplinary research
institutes at universities what there
isn't is a path for
young people who are interdisciplinary
from the start to get hired right the
path to become a professor
is to excel in a discipline
and get hired in that discipline and
then branch out later and that works
pretty darn well for many people but for
other people it just doesn't so i do
like the idea that one way or another
it should be possible to hire people as
professors
in a way that is not
the individual departments doing all the
work
um that is the way it is right now for
those of you maybe you're not in
universities or don't know uh at
universities it's departments that have
the power roughly speaking to hire and
promote people it's not the president of
the university or the provost or any or
the deans or whatever they will assign a
slot i mean they'll say okay you have
money to hire somebody and the
negotiation is more or less the
department will say okay we would like
to hire a biophysicist and the president
and the dean will say okay you have
money to do that or no you don't or you
know make a case why is biophysics
interesting etc and so there's a back
and forth there but when it comes to
choosing the person
98
of the work is done by the department
and what that means is if you have a
physics department a biology department
an economics department a history
department and they know
that
jobs are scarce right that they're not
going to get to hire that many people
they will as a department almost always
decide to hire people who fit well in
the boundaries of that department
and that just leaves out people who
don't fit well into those boundaries and
i think it's a huge mistake i think it's
a huge uh opportunity cost for universe
universities that want to do better
right you know universities should
always be competing with each other to
hire the best people do the best
research to be the best educators of the
best students this is a clear way i
think
that you could snap up a bunch of really
great people who are young and
imaginative are going to change the
world but don't fit exactly into
individual departments that's how how i
would put it anyway
i'm never going to be a university
administrator though so this might not
ever happen andrew goldstein says in
your blog describing the move to johns
hopkins you make reference to two
seminars
the one is entitled physics of democracy
which sounds disparate but very
intriguing even hopeful given current
events the other includes complexity and
emergence which is a passionate interest
to me so as an outsider might it be
possible to hear or read about any of
the discussions that will transpire
during these seminars i would gladly up
my membership to the quantum tier for
the privilege
um so yeah the second one that you're
referring to is an upper-level
undergraduate seminar just called topics
in philosophy of physics
so i will do a little bit of quantum
mechanics a little bit of the arrow of
time a little bit of the anthropic
principle and things like that
i think that's what you're referring to
and i'll also be talking about
complexity in the physics of democracy
class but neither one of these seminars
are going to be videotaped or online or
anything like that and i think that's
correct i think that's the right thing
to do um you know there's a big place
for videotaping things and handing them
out freely as as hopefully you know
because i do it all the time this
podcast is audio taped which and then
handed out freely and that counts um but
the biggest ideas in the universe videos
uh were also handed out freely but that
the place for that
is kind of broadcasting right when you
know the the role of having a video and
having people watch it is you have a
person
talking you know a person with knowledge
is trying to spread that knowledge to
the rest of the world that's when that
model works very well but a seminar is
not that model a seminar
at the university level we're going to
have like 15 students or fewer in the
room
much of the conversation is going to be
the students talking not me talking and
it's got to be a little protected from
criticism from the outside world you
have to feel like you're free to say
some stupid things because you don't
know
and if you're worried about saying
things in the world making fun of you
then you might not speak up when maybe
you should so i think it's a perfectly
good
place for
having seminars that are that are not
recorded that are just ephemeral you
know there's a moment there in the
classroom sitting around the table
people are talking to each other it's
it's fun it can be life-changing and
it's important and it's not for external
consumption there's other
cases where i don't think that cameras
should be allowed also like if you have
some really focused
workshop among your own research group
where you're bouncing back and forth
ideas that are not yet completely baked
and you want to build on them and write
papers and so forth you know that's not
for public consumption either so i'm a
huge believer in filming things and
letting them be shared
but that's not for everything some
things are like that and some things are
not the good news is that for the
physics of democracy i certainly hope to
write a book on the subject at some
point and that will um hopefully appear
for the foundations of physics seminar
i don't know whether i would ever write
anything about that but certainly
individual topics within that are things
that i write papers about right
including complexity and emergence the
anthropic principle the arrow of time
quantum mechanics things will get
written about that one way or the other
rob f says do you think progress in
answering the biggest questions of
modern physics will be primarily
achieved iteratively through
collaboration of large teams of
scientists or do you think it will
progress by a paradigm shift sparked by
a handful of genius individuals
the popular history of science seems to
suggest perhaps wrongly that great leaps
in understanding were made by
exceptionally gifted individuals newton
einstein etc but modern science seems
more of a collaborative effort put
another way do we have to wait for the
next einstein in order to make the next
great leap forward
i love this question i think it's very
important because the answer is in
between um there have been studies that
have purported to show
that super duper smart people are
way more influential in the history of
science than the average person i
actually don't believe these studies
because i think there's a methodological
flaw in them i think that what happens
is there are you know very very smart
people out there in the world but those
people absolutely lean on the efforts of
the other people who are they talk to
and collaborate with i mean
i understand there's history behind the
remark but when newton says he saw
further than others because he stole the
shoulders of giants uh he stood on the
shoulders of all sorts of people of
different heights and that was really
really important i mean in the biggest
picture sorry the biggest ideas book
that is going to come out i tell the
story
of how
very very briefly how newton was
inspired to write the principia
mathematica right you know the greatest
work in the history of physics where he
proposed newtonian mechanics and the
inverse square law for gravity and a bit
of calculus
you know there were other people who had
most of those ideas in particular robert
hook
had the idea that there was an inverse
square law of gravity okay and he had
the idea that would explain kepler's
laws of motion and the planets moving in
ellipses
uh he wasn't as good at math
as newton was so he couldn't quite prove
it he couldn't quite derive that the
motion in an inverse square potential or
inverse square law force law would be an
ellipse
and so hook and christopher wren and
robert halley of halley's comet fame uh
they used to get together and talk about
these things at the coffee shop and they
eventually you know um engaged hallie to
go visit newton who was up in cambridge
all these other people were in london
and asked newton because everyone knew
even at the time before the principia
there you know the word had gotten out
that newton was the smart one around
here
and you know when hallie asked him he
said yeah no i it'll be an ellipse
and halley's like how do you know he
said i calculated it and haley says well
why didn't you write anything yeah i
can't really be bothered to write these
things but you know hallie
provoked him to write about it and then
eventually that turned into the
principia um which which tells us both
that if it hadn't been newton it would
have been somebody else i mean given
that the idea of the inverse square law
was already there someone else would
have put it together
galilean relativity conservation of
momentum they were all already there
leibniz invented calculus not long after
newton you know etc etc but newton was
there and he was extraordinarily smart
and he did the greatest single
achievement in the history of physics
okay so i think it's both i think that
uh
super talented people play an outsized
role but they wouldn't be able to do it
without all the work of everyone else
and as even more important day when we
have these large collaborative efforts
it's sometimes hard to see
the impact of the smaller
incremental steps along the way but
they're important they're important for
the whole story
joelle curtis says do you think the fact
that our most successful theories
explain interactions and forces in terms
of local gauge symmetries is explanatory
in any deep sense does it tell us
something very important about nature or
our relationship to it
well i have no idea that's a very good
question um
i i honestly don't know and i think that
i think i my credence for answering
questions like this is less now than it
was 10 years ago because i've been
thinking about quantum gravity in the
meantime and gravity changes everything
a little bit
you know so for folks who are not
experts in these buzzwords
our best current theories of the world
in terms of predicting things and being
accurately mapped to data and so forth
uh are quantum field theories so quantum
mechanical field uh theories of fields
that pervade space and
in particular uh they have different
kinds of fields and the forces that we
think of electromagnetism the weak
nuclear force the strong nuclear force
and gravity for that matter
are all certain kind of field
defined by a certain kind of symmetry
called local gauge symmetries okay we
won't go into what that means but
there's a certain symmetry property that
helps explain the features of the forces
of nature
did it have to be that way
could it have been some other way is it
telling us something deep i don't know
and one of the reasons why i don't know
is because
just being a field theory
i don't think is right i don't think the
world is a field theory and the reason
why is because
in field theory there's an infinite
number of things going on in any one
region of space
and to me that means that there could in
principle be
an infinite amount of entropy in any
region of space right because entropy
counts the number of things that could
be going on in a region given its
macroscopic features and so if field
theory were right
then i claim that you could imagine
states in the universe where there's
arbitrarily large amounts of entropy in
any region but we know that's not true
or we think that's not true because
if you keep putting things in a region
of space the energy keeps going up and
eventually collapse into a black hole
and black holes have entropy but that
entropy is not infinite it's a finite
number so that tells us there's only a
finite number of things that can happen
in any one region of space and that
tells us that nature is not described by
a quantum field theory
now we're still working on understanding
the implications of that because
certainly the local gauge theories that
we use
are really super duper successful but
once gravity becomes important it seems
that they can't be fundamental even
though they're very successful how that
all fits together i don't know so it's
very very possible that the success of
gauge theories in our low energy
accessible world is not an accident does
reflect something really deep going on
at a profound level but it's also
possible
that in some sense it's an accident uh
in some sense it's an epiphenomenal
something that would be true
in you know some approximation but is
not very deep or fundamental i honestly
just don't know it's worth thinking
about
lester sue says are you able to explain
the context and implications of the
latest fermilab results on the w boson
so for those of you who don't know
fermilab
the giant particle accelerator facility
just outside of chicago recently
published a paper where they measured
the mass of the w boson w boson is one
of the two kinds of bosons we have
carrying the weak interactions it's a
boson that is an excitation of a local
gage field as we were just talking about
the z boson is the other kind z bosons
are neutral w bosons are charged their
masses are similar but a little bit
different and it's hard to measure the
mass for many many reasons but people
have been trying to do it and people
have been doing it and then the question
is
keep doing it and get more and more
accurate results the reason why it's an
especially interesting thing to do not
only are you saying well that's the
constant of nature the mass of the w
boson that would be nice to know
but
other
features of the world feed into the
measured mass of the w boson this is a
feature of quantum field theory that all
fields kind of vibrate around in the
background and affect the properties of
all the other fields
this is shows up when you think about
feynman diagrams and the fact that
the mass what is the mass it's just the
property of inertia of a particle moving
all by itself right the mass you would
think doesn't have anything to do with
interactions if you just have a particle
not interacting just moving it still has
a mass right or even just sitting there
it has a mass
but in quantum field theory the feynman
diagrams are telling you that as that
particle is just sitting there it is
interacting with all the other fields
around it and these are quantified by
little loops that you can draw in the
vitamin diagrams and those loops will
eventually connect the properties of
that particle sitting there to all the
other properties of all the other fields
in the universe
so in principle
by measuring things like the mass of the
w boson and other particles you can tell
whether there are
other fields that we haven't yet
directly detected in any other particle
accelerator you can say that there are
consistency relations between things
like the mass of the w boson the mass of
the higgs and the mass of the top quark
okay
and so this new result from fermilab
seems to be telling us
that at a statistically significant
level the mass of the w boson is a
little bit bigger than we thought before
and is not consistent with the standard
model of particle physics but would be
consistent if there were somehow some
other particles that were feeding into
the w and giving it a little bit of
extra mass
i'm not going to tell any details about
what those models look like you can
check out matt strassler's
blog where he talks about those things
or or other if you go to archive i'm
sure there's many many models have
appeared since this happened
but here's the context which should make
you be cautious about the whole thing
you know it's fermilab that is getting
this result right it's not the large
hadron collider that's at cern outside
geneva in switzerland
i didn't even know fermilab was still
running you might say to yourself and
you'd be correct because fermilab's
accelerator the tevatron
turned off in the year 2011.
so this analysis is not because fermilab
has collected new data it's because it
has been analyzing more carefully the
data that was collected in 2011 and
before
which is fine you're allowed to do that
but this result is not compatible with
previous results either from fermilab
itself or from the lhc in switzerland
maybe it's like close to being
compatible in the error bars or whatever
but it's clearly not precisely
compatible and so it's both based on old
data and it's it's incompatible with
previous results so if there is some
amount of credence you have
that this is just a goof
that somehow there was some systematic
effect in the accelerator or the
detector or the data analysis pipeline
this would be
a you know above average
chance for something like that to happen
and you know if they had just measured
it and gotten the right answer the
answer everyone thought was the correct
one they would people would think it
would be perfectly fine but it is
okay
to be more skeptical about dramatic
claims right um and this is one where
you know
that there's sort of a root to
skepticism if that's what you want to
take on this at the same time the people
who are actually doing the analysis et
cetera they know what they're doing you
know they're not dummies they're they
know their detector uh pretty darn well
better than anybody else does and they
wouldn't say something dramatic like
this unless they thought that they had
double checked every possible single
thing that would cause this to happen so
we'll have to wait
we'll have to see if better um data or
experiments
from lhc or elsewhere are able to pin it
down otherwise i would not get too
excited just yet but it would be very
cool if it were true
cathy seeger says how best to argue with
people who claim that ukraine should
surrender because they can't win on
their own and an active involvement of
nato would maybe lead to a third world
war or nuclear strike i get the argument
in a way but it still feels flat out
wrong to let me
to me to let russia win the war and get
away with atrocities from a moral
philosophy point of view what would you
say
so i don't know if cathy you yourself
were inspired by this but a claim close
to that claim was uh famously debated
just a little while ago because noam
chomsky of all people said it you know
noam chomsky famous
uh for many things linguistics most
prominently but also as a
leftist critique of imperialism etc
and
there's a there's a worry that you know
you get so interested in critiquing
american european uh imperialism that
you sort of take it easy on imperialism
from other places from china or russia
or whatever so that was the counter
argument to chomsky because chomsky is
basically saying look ukraine can't win
uh they should just uh you know take it
take rather than sacrificing themselves
they should uh you know let russia
basically win i don't know exactly the
word so don't quote me on that you can
go look it up but there are certainly
people who have that point of view
there's no question um
i
do not see any justification for me to
tell ukraine what to do about this uh i
think that throughout history there have
been
stories of countries or people
who've been attacked against
overwhelming odds and have resisted and
sometimes their resistance has worked
and sometimes it hasn't but there is
something since you asked for the moral
philosophy point of view there is
something intrinsically noble about the
resistance about fighting for your
country uh for your freedom against a uh
authoritarian oppressor who is evading
invading you so i think there's
something noble about what ukraine is
doing and i you know i i'm not going to
give them advice look what i mean when i
say i'm not going to give them advice is
if they wanted to surrender
if they said look it is you know we're
hurting ourselves too many people are
dying too many atrocities we have to end
this even if it means surrendering to
the imperialist aggressor i would not
criticize them for doing that but i
certainly won't criticize them for
continuing to resist i mean go them go
ukrainians they have shown enormous
courage and pluck and and the whole
world is rooting them for very good
reasons
the harder thing to do is to say what um
other countries should do and you know i
have no influence over what ukraine does
i also have no influence over what the
united states does so it's just me
talking i you know i don't have any uh
policy levers to pull on this one
but it's an interesting weird kind of
dance isn't it because
of course as i said in the last ama
world war three would be bad you know
having literally hundreds of millions of
people die
is an outcome uh because of nuclear
weapons throwing back and forth is an
outcome to be avoided at all costs i i
think um
so that is why nato and the u.s et
cetera do not want to send troops to the
ukraine because then those troops would
fight russian troops and it'll be war
between nato and russia and that war
could escalate to
nuclear weapons i'm i'm completely on
board with that worry i think that's a
very uh
reasonable worry but what's weird about
it is
we are allowed to send weapons right
like somehow
we
by we i mean like the collective
humanity uh have decided that if we send
weapons or food or resources of some
sort to ukraine and they use them to
fight against russia that's not an act
of war
so i think it's okay i'm not arguing
against it but just the philosopher in
me wants to say
that's a particular place that you've
chosen to draw a line between two things
and i bet that that line would not stand
up under very very strict scrutiny
helping ukraine one way versus another
seems to me to be the the issue but you
know as long as it prevents a nuclear
war i'm happy to go along with the
conventional understanding anyway i'm
very very happy that we give
ukrainians resources to fight against
the invading army
robert ruxin's rescue says imagine i
write to you a sentence in romanian my
native language for you it will look
like a random sequence of letters with
no meaning or information in them for me
that sentence would be meaningful and
have a lot of information
what then can be said of the
relationship between information and
entropy it seems like what we call low
entropy is arbitrary
so i like how you are assuming that i
don't speak romanian
in this case your assumption is
completely correct because i do not
speak a word of romanian um
but this is you know it's a perfectly
good question but there are perfectly
good answers to this this is not i don't
think this is a very mysterious at the
fundamental level um it becomes
mysterious because we use the word
information in different ways
okay so there is a sense of information
that claude shannon introduced where it
really is a perfectly objective
quantitative thing based on the
frequencies of different symbols coming
your way right so if someone sends you a
text in romanian
you can look at the frequency with which
different letters are used or different
words are used etc and talk about the
entropy of a message
in the sense that
given that
language even if i don't understand it
semantically if i don't know what it's
supposed to be telling me about the
world i can still say that within this
language a certain message is
information packed or not very
informative at all that's a purely
mathematical statement and how you
should think about it is
certain sentences are surprising they
don't appear very often they therefore
convey a lot of information if someone
says the sun rises in the east versus
saying the sun rose today in the west
even though the length of the sentences
are the same one conveys much more
information
because we already knew the sun rises in
the east telling me it rose in the east
this morning doesn't give me any more
information that i didn't already have
telling me it rose in the west which is
not a common sentence that you would
hear people say would if it were true
convey a lot of information so in that
sense of the word information
it doesn't matter whether i can speak
romanian or not i can still talk about
the entropy
um there's another sense though i mean
like you say there's this connection
between the words and the meanings of
the words out there in the world and
there
it's still an answerable question the
point is that there's different ways of
course graining right the same exact
text
might have no information content from
the perspective of a certain observer
and a lot of information content from
the perspective of another observer
let's say that there's an observer who
interprets it as romanian and
understands what it means and another
who interprets it as english and
therefore gets nothing out of it
they have different ways of course
grading they have different ways of
dividing the space of letters up into
words etc and calculating its entropy
and so they would get different answers
for that so in that sense it's not
arbitrary but it's relative to the
course grading it's relative to the way
that you're looking at the world when it
comes to actual physical systems not
strings of text letters
there are ways that we all as human
beings look at the world and we course
grain in the same way that's why using
the ideas of information and entropy and
the connection between them is not
arbitrary in practical purposes
sean coram says
can photons have arbitrarily high energy
or would an energetic enough photon turn
into a black hole
nope photons cannot turn into black
holes why because there's no such thing
as a photon having an arbitrarily high
energy why because energy is not an
intrinsic concept to the photon the
energy is not lorenzen variant right you
know we know that objects have kinetic
energy as well as rest energy rest
energy equals mc squared plus kinetic
energy but the kinetic energy depends on
their velocity depends on their motion
and that's relative to who's observing
it right if i'm in the rest frame of the
object it has zero kinetic energy
likewise for a photon even though it
moves at the speed of light i can still
change my reference frame and observe
its energy in different reference frames
and there's always a reference frame in
which the photon looks like it's low
energy there's always another reference
frame in which it looks like it's high
energy so there's no such thing as a
photon just having high energy once and
for all and therefore there's no danger
that it turns into a black hole
brad dowden says do you recommend that
we say the arrow of time is entropy
increase or instead is whatever the
entropy of the universe does
uh i recommend that we say the arrow of
time is
all of the ways in which the past is
different from the future okay
so one of those ways is that entropy is
increasing entropy was lower in the past
will be higher in the future but there
are other ways we already talked about
causality there's memory there's aging
and biology and evolution of the
universe and evolution of
the
ecosystem things like that okay those
are all defining
uh
version not versions but
features of the arrow of time
the
next correct statement is that the
reason why
there are all of these arrows of time is
because entropy is increasing
so that is the single thing that enables
all these other asymmetries between past
and future so the fact that entropy is
increasing is the reason why there is an
error of time i would not say that it is
the arrow of time
alex ellis says more than once i've
heard statements along the lines that
many worlds is the only interpretation
of quantum mechanics that doesn't add
anything it just follows directly from
the math
what does that mean no equation or
mathematical process means anything
unless you attach meanings to the
mathematical entities involved
uh sure so that's a not a very accurate
or at least somewhat sloppy statement
that you have quoted many worlds is the
only interpretation quantum mechanics
that directly follows the math
what the correct statement is that the
ontology and dynamics of many worlds are
the simplest ones
it says that there is nothing but a
quantum state
which is an element of hilbert's space
and the quantum state evolves according
to the schrodinger equation that's what
many worlds says
uh it says in other words there are not
other degrees of freedom there are not
other dynamical laws
there are not other ways of thinking
about it involving agents or experiences
or anything like that so of course just
like any other physical theory you have
to be able to explain how this
mathematical formalism
accounts for the world right so like if
you tell me the earth goes around the
sun how do i get that from a state
evolving in hilbert space right
according to the schroedinger equation
of course you have to do that but that's
no different for many worlds than
anything else the the correct statement
is
the minimal ingredients that are part of
everyone's theory of quantum mechanics
namely wave functions in the schrodinger
equation are the only ingredients you
need for
uh many worlds nothing there's no
statement that is especially mathy or
anti-mathy about many worlds it's no
more or less than any other physical
theory
claudio says i notice that wormholes are
being mentioned more often lately what's
the current understanding of wormholes
and what would be evidence of their
existence
uh i don't know what um social media
you're listening in on where wormholes
are being mentioned more lately but you
know wormholes are a hypothetical
construct that were made famous by
einstein and collaborators but there are
other people talking about them
where you can basically use the fact
that in general relativity space-time is
curved to imagine building a tunnel
through space-time so building a little
wormhole as it were connecting to
different parts of the universe and the
really cool part about it is in this
imagination space where we're just
making things up we're not worried about
what actually happens in the real world
you can imagine wormholes that are
shortcuts so even though i'm here and
someone else is on alpha centauri i can
imagine
a version of space-time in which there
is a wormhole where it would take me
four light years to get to alpha
centauri the usual way going near the
speed of light but it only take me a day
to get there through the wormhole the
distance would be shorter okay
so the short answer is i don't think
there are any wormholes i don't think
this is a part of the real world um
people have tried and they have not
completely succeeded in saying it's
impossible to make a wormhole what they
have shown is that if you try lots of
bad things happen
generally speaking um if you try to make
a wormhole what actually happens is
everything collapses into a black hole
it's very very similar to the cosmic
censorship conjecture
cosmic censorship says that the only
singularities appear beyond event
horizons of black holes it's a similar
thing with wormholes when you get right
down to it but there are technical
details that we don't need to go into
but from the thought experiment point of
view they're very very interesting a lot
of work being done these days in the ads
cft correspondence
uses wormholes of various kinds but
they're not trying to model the real
world they're trying to learn general
principles that might somehow tell us
about it
and of course as kip thorne and others
realized long ago
if you have a shortcut through space you
can go backwards in time so wormholes
are useful both to travel
great distances through space and also
maybe to enable time travel which might
be depending on your stance on these
things a reason not to think that there
are any wormholes because time travel
would be a mess in its own right
tarun says where do you stand on hume's
skepticism toward the principle of
induction and what this means for the
validity of science
well you know i'm a bayesian so i don't
think that there's any principle of
induction that is any hard and fast rule
you know the principle of induction if
we
what was it ever supposed to be i'm not
sure if you see a white swan and a white
swan and a white swan
when it when do you reach the point
where therefore there are no black swans
i mean you just get more and more
credence right like good bayesian has
just no problem with this you say well
if we live in a world where half the
swans were white and half were black
versus a world where they were all white
and none of them were black the
probability of seeing a hundred white
swans in a row would be very high in one
and very low in the other so i'm going
to increase my credence in the one that
is more likely to be true but i admit
that the next one i see might be black
right
so
that that's one sort of the cheap and
easy part of the the answer to that
question like the principle of induction
was never supposed to be never or never
had any good reason to be taken uh
completely seriously as a way to get
um
reliable knowledge of the world
the other of course like like hiding
here
is the issue that any good bayesian has
about the priors that you have for all
of your um credences so you know this is
the nelson goodman
is a philosopher who pointed out look
you know when we're trying to do
induction
what are we inducting on like what are
the properties that we're measuring so
when we talk about the swans it was
either white or black right and you say
it's white as white as white as white
every swan i've ever seen is white
therefore they're probably all white
even a good bayesian would be tempted to
say something like that right not a
hundred percent but if you see a million
white swans in a row you become pretty
confident so what goodman says is
for some reason he went with uh blue and
green instead instead of white and black
uh but he says look
let me define a property called
gru
and gru is
green up until the year
2100
and blue after the year 2100 right
that's a property absolutely true
um and he says look
so far when i see you know my um i don't
know shishito pepper uh every shishito
pepper i've seen is green and therefore
i'm tempted to say it'll be green
forever but it's also true that every
shishito pepper i've ever seen is grew
right because they're all green before
the year 2100 and it's compatible that
they'll be blue after the year 2100
so how do i know
which
conclusion to draw
and for the bayesian language what this
is saying is what are the priors that
you put on different propositions and it
might your prior might be much higher
that the wavelengths of light reflected
by this by this vegetable uh remain
constant versus changing into something
else right or something like that but
you still have to ask where those priors
come from and i'm very happy to say that
they're a little bit subjective right
that we human beings invent priors
because we have a pre-existing image of
the world the manifest image that gives
us certain predilections towards certain
ways of thinking that the world behaves
and that's where our priors come from
and different people will have slightly
different priors etc but
that is uh where the subjectivity comes
in and that's okay like you know the
short short answer to all of these
questions is
pre-hume there was a real
effort to put everything on a firm
foundation right you didn't really have
knowledge unless it was kind of like
math like it was kind of like
absolute truth descended from
completely believable postulates or
axioms and i think that the
the usefulness of what hume did was to
undermine that program and to soften
people up even though hume didn't have
all the final answers he softened people
up for
accepting the idea that uh knowledge is
a little bit more fallibilistic a little
bit more approximate a little bit more
um
probabilistic in some sense something we
work toward getting higher and higher
credences and things rather than getting
them true once and for all
jeffrey seagal says i enjoyed everything
everywhere all at once but i need to
defend the everything bagel as my
favorite bagel what is your favorite
bagel and do you have an alternative
candidate for the bad bagel
um
uh so i don't wanna no no spoiler alerts
but there is an everything bagel in the
movie everything everywhere all at once
it plays an important role
um and i love everything bagels i don't
think that you should need to defend it
and i don't think the movie is
necessarily anti-everything bagel still
not a spoiler don't worry um
i also just like garlic bagels or onion
bagels they'd like the savory bagels so
my alternative candidate for bad bagel
would be something sweet right
but you know in the right circumstances
a blueberry bagel with some you know
strawberry cream cheese or something
like that is perfectly fine so i don't
think there are any bad bagels there are
just bad bagel eaters
bruno teshera says after the podcast
with nicole younger halpern do you still
stand by the statement that we have
already discovered all the laws of
physics that affect our everyday lives
well technically no uh i do not stand by
that statement but i've never made that
statement it is not a statement that i
would ever make the statement i actually
make is that we know uh we completely
understand the laws of physics
underlying the everyday world and all
the words in that statement matter you
can't just kind of leave some words out
and get a statement that is equally true
in particular the word underlying is
very very true nobody in their right
mind thinks that we understand all of
the laws of physics at all of the levels
of analysis you might want to think
about we don't understand i don't know
why bumblebees fly how they fly i'm not
even sure that's true or if that's an
urban myth we don't understand high
temperature superconductivity we don't
understand what the dark matter is
plenty of things uh we don't understand
and
the specific
statement that i've tried to make is
that we understand the laws of physics
in one domain at one level and that
level is the standard model of particle
physics plus general relativity the core
theory nothing that nicole and i talked
about is in any sense incompatible with
the standard model plus general
relativity so there's no reason why i
would change my stance on that
particular statement
brad malt says
we your loyal listeners i appreciate the
loyalty brad thank you
seem to be continually asking questions
reflecting our confusion about
improbable branches of the multiverse in
the april ama this took the form of a
question about the meaning of making
moral choices and you counseled us not
to be discouraged because the bad branch
of the wave function was improbable i
think we would stop asking this question
if you could articulate why thin worlds
are any less real for instance if there
is a 99 chance of a good world and a 1
chance of a bad world aren't there just
two worlds fifty percent of which are
bad you say the worlds don't count
equally but why not and in what sense um
this is a perfectly good question as you
say versions of it have been asked many
times i predict that i can articulate it
very well and it will not stop people
from asking the questions and that's not
because people are stubborn it's because
it's a it's
a very different kind of thing this is a
an issue that arises in the many worlds
interpretation that just doesn't arise
in other theories and therefore you know
it's okay
to
struggle with understanding what is
going on here um the mathy way to say it
is that
in quantum mechanics in in many worlds
quantum mechanics the quantum state of
the universe is a vector
and the different worlds are components
of that vector so if you imagine a
simple example where there's a vector in
x y plane right
i draw an arrow going from the origin to
some point x comma y and i could project
it down to the x axis and over to the y
axis to get its components
now let's say that my coordinates of the
uh
the tail the head of the vector i don't
know which one is which the arrow
is x equals one y equals ten okay
so i have two components the x component
has length one the y component has
length 10.
but you would not
be tempted to say
the there's two components they're equal
i think that these two components matter
the same right one component is 10 times
longer than the other one is and that's
what the world is in quantum mechanics
the world is a vector and these
different components
are the different the world the the
quantum state of the universe is a
vector and the different individual
worlds are components of that vector
components can be bigger or smaller
that's the that's the basic fact
that's the mathy version if you want a
more sort of uh physical version
think of it this way
we want to be able to compare different
worlds uh we we need to be able to say
that some worlds do count more than
others and the reason why we need to be
able to say that is because we do want
to assign more probability to seeing
some result okay and if you don't think
that's possible if you just take a
stubborn view or says i i'm not allowed
to assign different
amount of worlds then you don't believe
many worlds so you don't have an issue
you can't make many worlds work unless
you're willing to make that metaphysical
step and then if you are willing to make
that metaphysical step the question is
okay how do i do it how do i assign
uh amounts of um oomph to the different
worlds width thickness whatever you want
to call it should it just be 50 50
should it just be equal for every world
and the answer is that that possibility
of trying to give equal oomph to every
world just fails it just fails right
away and one way of seeing that is think
about if i were to split one world into
three okay so now i have three worlds
and you're going to say
well i'm going to give them equal for
equal thickness equal width so it's one
third one third one third right
but now instead of splitting into three
so let's keep that in mind
now let's imagine i just split into two
okay so i
measure a spin or something like that i
get two outcomes i now two worlds and i
split into two
but i agree ahead of time
that if i get spin down i'm going to
split again
right if i get spin up i'm not going to
split again
so in that case i first split into two
worlds and now you're saying well i'm
gonna give him one half one half right
and now we split again the other world
now the choice is either
i
give that world that is now split one
quarter one quarter for each of its
successors right because it was half for
the first splitting and then another
half for the second splitting so it's
one quarter one quarter
so the the spin up world gets a half and
the other two worlds get a quarter
or
i say
okay let me say why that's that doesn't
make sense the reason why that doesn't
make sense is
if i take the limit as that second
splitting happens closer and closer and
closer to the first one
then
i can't tell the difference there
becomes no difference that limit should
be continuous it should be smooth
there's no difference between splitting
into three all at once and splitting
into two and then conditionally
splitting into another two really really
really really quickly i'd better get the
same answer
so
one quarter one quarter one-half is a
different answer than one-third
one-third one-third so that doesn't work
so instead you might say oh okay when i
do the second splitting i will update
i will redo my idea of what the
thickness of all the worlds is and i'll
give it one-third one-third one-third
but then you know for for those of us
who are on the spin-up world we had
thought that our world was half of all
the thickness and now something that
happened in a completely different world
reduced us to one third of the thickness
and that doesn't make sense either right
you're like oh my goodness none of this
makes sense whatever are we to do
well the answer is
give given amount of thickness that is
given by the bourne rule given by the
wave function squared the you know x
squared plus y squared equals the length
of the arrow squared that is the
conserved quantity that is that is there
all the time
so i know it's very different than what
you're used to
but if you accept many worlds at all you
have to count the worlds unequally let
me give you a third way of thinking
about this or a third justification for
doing it this way
let's say that you do you want to
treat some worlds as equally thick or
equally important okay
well you know since it is the component
of a vector
maybe you say well at least i will treat
worlds equally thickly if they have the
same amplitude right if the component
has the same length then i could treat
it equally right if it's spin up and
spin down it's literally 1 over square
root of 2 spin up plus 1 over square
root of 2 spin down and then i make that
measurement now i should treat it
equally so that's okay yes you are
allowed to do that but then what does
that imply
when the amplitudes are not equal
what it implies is that if i have two
unequal amplitudes then i could ask for
the two different components the two
different worlds what if i subdivide
them
unequally right what if i subdivide them
until they're subdivided into a number
of worlds such that their amplitudes are
are equal right so i keep slicing until
they have equal sizes of the pie so i
get you know
two-thirds of one world and one-third of
the other world but then i take the
two-thirds world and put it one more
time right and so then i get worlds with
equal amplitudes i assign them equal
width or thickness and i ask what does
that imply pre-splitting what does that
imply before i did that extra splitting
well what it implies is the width of the
two-thirds world was two-thirds right
that's what works so
if you want to assign equal width to
worlds with equal amplitudes that means
you should use the bourne rule
the wave function squared when you don't
have equal amplitudes so no matter what
way you slice it no matter what way you
come at the problem if you want to make
sense of the world in many worlds you
have to assign a
meaningfulness thickness oomph whatever
you want to call it which is
proportional to the wavefunction squared
if you don't think many worlds make
sense that's a different question but
that's what you need to do in many
worlds
ford prefect says in principle could
there exist a particularly lucky
configuration of massive objects in the
universe that would happen to bend light
in such a way so that by observing it we
could snoop into our past and see how
dinosaurs are being wiped out by an
asteroid
well
in principle
there could be but let's emphasize
precisely how impractical it is uh for
one thing when you have things like
stars and planets which have
gravitational fields that do bend light
the amount of light bending is really
really tiny if you want anything close
to several degrees of bending you're
gonna need something like a black hole
okay so you have black holes out there
in the universe but what's happening is
the earth is
sending light out in all directions
and that light is spreading out as it
goes further and further away from the
earth so even if there was like a
configuration of black holes somewhere
out there in the galaxy many light years
away
which had exactly the property that a
single beam of light precisely targeted
could zoom out from the earth wrap
around so you know the dinosaurs were
what 65 million years ago so it would
have to be
32.5 light million light years away very
very far in another galaxy so some
photon could go exactly in the right
configuration and come exactly back to
us
but think about it what would the photon
next to it do
well it's so thinly spread out that it
would not come anywhere close to um
following it would be in a different
path it would be diverging because all
the photons are moving apart as they
leave the earth think about it this way
think about taking a picture of the
earth from the orbit of pluto just with
a video camera you're not going to see
that much right the earth will be a
little tiny dot that's all it's going to
be uh in fact that's literally the pale
blue dot image that was taken by the
voyager spacecraft it's just it's just a
dot you're not going to get any images
and that's just the void that's just the
the um orbit of pluto that's not 35
million light years away right so for
all intents and purposes this is not
really going to happen the other thing
is you know this is an elaborate setup
to do something pretty simple like if
you really want to capture
images from the past just take a picture
let's take a photograph now admittedly
we don't have any photographs from 65
million years ago but we have other
records we have fossils right we have
footprints we have bones and things like
that and you might say well that's not
as detailed as we would like
yeah it's it's not but it is much much
much more detailed than we would ever
get from light that was uh sent off to
some black hole 35 million light years
away 32.5 million layers away and then
sent back to us
tom says i enjoyed your recent
conversation with daniels and
subsequently saw the movie i'm curious
if you have ever
if you ever had any ideas for movies or
creative projects of your own i know
you've consulted on the physics
portrayed on film but what about a
screenplay of your own um yeah i've
absolutely thought about it i've even um
i don't want to say collaborated that
sounds too um gives me too much credit i
have talked to friends of mine who are
screenwriters
about maybe collaborating it's never
really gotten off the ground
entirely my fault that it's never really
gotten off the ground because i just too
many other things going on and
i've had situations where let's put it
this way if i had really devoted myself
to getting this screenplay written uh it
would have been written i'm not gonna
say the movie would be made the vast
majority of screenplays never get made
in this town um but i think that'll be a
lot of fun i'm very much interested in
that i'm not giving up on it yet but
still there's plenty of other things i
got to get done first
ken wolfe says i think that one of the
key questions in the future of
artificial intelligence is whether or
not something like
human level artificial general
intelligence can be developed without
creating a conscious entity i'm not
asking whether you think this is
possible since i don't think anyone can
answer that
at this point my question is whether you
think an advanced agi with or without
subjective conscious experience
represents a greater existential threat
to humanity and why
well um i have a couple of comments here
none of which are going to be really
satisfying answers to your question i
don't know what what it means to say
that a certain agi artificial general
intelligence has consciousness or not
not that i'm saying it's impossible to
answer i i'm not so i'm not saying that
in the sense of saying oh i don't know
what that means because i don't think it
makes sense i just mean i don't know
what it means i'm not exactly sure how
to draw that line i'm perfectly willing
to believe that adi could be conscious i
just don't know what the criteria are
um so i have no idea i just don't have a
good answer to the actual question of
whether one an agi with or without
consciousness is the bigger threat also
you know i don't know
what the origin of the threat is this is
a slightly different issue than what
you're asking but um
how does the
super intelligent conscious ai actually
threaten me like i can imagine if we
turned over all of the
levers and buttons that controlled our
economy or our military that would be a
threat but maybe we could have an agi
but didn't give it any access to the
economy or the military so i'm not
exactly sure
what the precise scenario to worry about
is and i think that uh it's all a little
vague and i would be more interested in
this issue if it were a little bit more
specific what it was i should be
worrying about
henry jacobs says
perspective free will is a bad theory
not because it's false but because it's
not a theory thoughts
follow up so this is a parody of a quote
of you roughly replacing free will with
god and i suspect even the explanation
logic is isomorphic
am i being lazy um so
yes i think you're being lazy or at
least you're being very wrong sorry
about that henry but you know you asked
the questions you kind of opened
yourself up for it um look i had i've
given a talk called god is not a good
theory
um you should watch the talk uh because
in the beginning of it i tell the
amusing story of how you can find on
youtube
in the it was at a
conference at oxford on uh cosmology and
theology and the intersections between
them
and in the
program for the conference the title of
my talk was listed incorrectly it was
listed as god is not a theory and i tell
the story of how that is exactly the
opposite of what i think that is why the
title of my actual talk was god is not a
good theory
if it's not a good theory it is a theory
it's just a bad theory that is exactly
the point that i was trying to make so
you seem to be under the impression that
i think that god is not a good theory
because it's not a good because it's not
a theory but that is the opposite of
what i believe so i do not think that
the
cut and replace that you are um
suggesting has much of whatsoever sorry
coopervite says priority question
remember i keep forgetting to mention
this but priority questions are
every person who is a patreon of
mindscape gets to ask a question once in
their life
that i promise to answer or at least try
to answer i do not promise the answer
will be satisfactory
but i will i will not ignore it there's
too many questions so i have to delete
some questions
and therefore uh sometimes you know
you're really interested in a question
that i'm not
this is the way that you can get your
question answered by labeling it as a
priority but you only get to do it once
in your life so make it good so cooper
says
on the issue of morality adam smith
talked about a sympathetic observer
someone who will be able to sum up the
net most preferable alternative outcome
or macro state do you think net
preferability is remotely scientific
um i am i have mixed feelings about this
one i think it's a good question so
again my mixed feelings are because
they're really mixed not because i think
it's an ill-posed question
uh there's let me say two things one
thing is that if you have some decision
procedure if you have some way of saying
in the circumstances these circumstances
you should act in a certain way okay
this is the moral thing to do
you can always translate any decision
procedure into a procedure of maximizing
some function right even if it's a very
trivial thing of the function equals one
on decisions that you should make and
the function equals zero on decisions
you shouldn't make so there's always
some way to mathematize and to think of
a decision procedure or a theory of
morality of what is right and what is
wrong as assigning numbers to things so
that can't be the objection to this kind
of thing but there can be an objection
namely what kind of number are you
assigning the idea and this is sort of
you know proto
utilitarian consequentialist right uh
summing up the net most preferable
alternative what what exactly is it if i
understand your question correctly
cooper um you're asking what exactly is
it that i'm summing up and is the thing
that i'm summing up something that is
sensibly summed up you know just because
we can use words like summing things up
doesn't mean that it makes sense to sum
things up you cannot add up the number
three to the coffee cup in front of me
it doesn't make any sense yeah you're
adding two things in different spaces
that do not have an addition uh
operation defined on the the set that is
their union so that's a real worry right
that the idea being there's something
called preferability
that we can attach numbers to
and then we can add them up i do think
that again maybe
there is a trivial sense in which this
is always possible in principle but i
have big worries about it uh as in
practice that there is
um
i mean there's assumptions being made
here you know maybe about the linearity
for example you know if i have two
people uh that for some reason their
preferences or their utility or whatever
you want to call it is one half each and
that's equal
under some calculation to a person with
preference one and another with
preference zero i'm not sure that does
make sense but i can't rule it out i i
don't think it's the practical way to go
about doing these things i think that
it's sort of maybe this is what you're
getting at with your question i think
that it
sounds more rigorous and quantitative
and sciency than it really is i think
that uh the right thing to do
is not necessarily phrased in those
terms that that would be my position but
it's not a position i hold very strongly
i'd be i'd be willing to talk into
something better with a convincing
counter proposal
david colbert says i've recently dipped
my toe into exploring ancient greek
schools of philosophy or perhaps more
accurately life philosophies
like stoicism or at least its more
modern incarnation appeals to me do you
find any such life philosophies
intriguing or do you eschew adherence to
things like this in much the way same
way as you dislike hero worship
well i think it's a different
thing than hero worship but there is a
similarity so
a school of thought or a philosophy is a
set of ideas you know adhering to a set
of ideas is not the same as hero worship
in my mind i'm very much in favor of
adhering some ideas that make sense i'm
a i'm a naturalist there you go i'm a
many worlds person you can attach all
sorts of isms to me i think that there's
a certain kind of person that uh says oh
i don't like isms
but i think that isms are really helpful
you know they they if they're well
designed um and you don't you know take
them overly harshly that is to say you
don't insist that everyone adhere to the
rules in some kind of overly precise way
they convey information when you say
someone is a socialist or a fascist or
whatever hopefully information is
contained by saying those things
likewise with schools of thought of
ancient greece or anywhere else east
asia
or
indigenous americans or whoever these
are philosophies that you are welcome to
adhere to if you want to now personally
maybe this is what you're getting at
i wouldn't
take these schools of philosophy as
looking for the right one as a set of
things that one of them is right and we
should figure out which one is right and
then follow that i think that any of
them are worth looking at four good
ideas you know for that matter religious
traditions are also perfectly good
sources of good ideas just as they are
sources of bad ideas also what matters
to me is the quality of the idea much
more than where it comes from so if you
can read
texts from ancient stoics or for that
matter epicureans or whoever uh and get
good ideas for living your contemporary
life and i think that's great and good
for you chris says i think you've talked
about morality as being emergent but not
scientific so i'd like to ask how this
how you view these as compatible it
seems by emerging you mean that it's
built from things described by the
fundamental laws so if this view is
taken for morality why would that not be
investigated scientifically too like how
the emerging physics of fluids is
studied scientifically wouldn't it seem
that either morality is not emergent or
it has to be able to be studied
scientifically so
i i certainly have never said words like
morality is not scientific the words
that i might have said are that morality
is not a science
you cannot derive moral conclusions from
the same way that you can derive
scientific conclusions namely you put
forward hypotheses and then you test
them experimentally right that's how you
derive scientific conclusions that's how
you figure out what is the correct
scientific point of view um that is
because in science there are
alternate worlds right alternate
possibilities like maybe there's a world
in which newtonian mechanics was right
maybe there's a possible world not
actual worlds necessarily but
hypothetical worlds in which
the axion is the dark matter another
hypothetical world in which a weakly
interacting massive supersymmetric
particles the dark matter and we're
trying to do observations to figure out
which world we live in it's not that one
can be
driven to the right conclusion just by
thinking about it or talking about it
and that's just not how morality works
right you know no one is saying well
here's a moral possibility and here's
another moral possibility let's do an
experiment to see which one fits the
data that's just ain't how it works for
morality um
i do so i'm not a moral realist so
that's why i don't think that you can
study morality scientifically
i do think that morality is part of
the level at which we describe the world
that is emergent the level involving
human beings and their interactions
because human beings describe the world
in moral terms and they say this is good
this action this is bad etc human beings
do that so it's not fundamental it's
emergent in that sense
but my point about morality is that
i mean there's two things there's two
questions to ask about morality one is
what are the morals that people have
that question can be studied
scientifically right we can say well if
people have these morals they will do
this or they will say that and then we
can go investigate it
the other question is what are the
morals that people should have
that question cannot be investigated
scientifically different people have
different morals they're going to make
them up on the basis of different things
and there's no once and for all right
answer again scientifically there's a
once and for all right answer but in
morality there's not so you can study
aspects of morality scientifically but
you can't find the right morality by
doing science in the same way that you
can find the right dark matter candidate
by doing science
peter solfest says when i hear the heat
death of the universe described it is
usually described as roughly as a giant
void with some lonely low energy photons
floating around
if that's the case what would have
happened to all the lumps of iron are
they just not mentioned or is there some
decay process that would also wipe them
out at some point
it's definitely the decay process it
will take a very very long time but even
lumps of iron will eventually go away we
don't exactly know how so one
possibility and maybe the most likely
the most popular one
is that protons are not perfectly stable
okay
protons have never in the real world
been observed to decay there are limits
on the proton lifetime that are
something like 10 to the 35 years
but there are also theories that predict
the proton lifetime is 10 to the 36
years so that's very very plausible that
iron nuclei are not perfectly stable
they just decay when the protons decay
because the protons would decay into
lighter particles that would then fly
away and eventually that would happen to
all the protons and all the neutrons
once you got rid of some protons in the
iron when i say protons decay
neutrons will also decay
we don't say that because we know that
neutrons decay neutrons all by
themselves out there in the world have a
lifetime of something like 10 minutes
but protons in observed in the world as
far as we know are stable
but maybe they're not perfectly
maybe also those theories especially
grand unified theories in which protons
are not stable are not correct again we
have no experimental evidence for them
but even then there is something called
gravity right so an iron nucleus could
in principle decay to a black hole
and that black hole would evaporate away
or maybe we don't know what it would
decay into because we don't understand
quantum gravity but there could be some
gravity-like process by which the
the nature of the iron nucleus changes
into something else that would be super
super rare much slower than the decay of
the protons by grand unification or
something like that
but the good news is that we know
gravity exists right so if you wait long
enough it would happen uh the iron
nucleus would decay into other things
um i have no idea how long it will take
but you know eventually it would happen
and likewise for bigger things like
rocks and so forth our and all of this
is hypothetical like all this is
speculative we haven't been around for
10 to the 100 years or whatever um but
it's based on very straightforward
physics it's pretty solid stuff i'd be
i'd be surprised if there were any
individual
collections of protons and neutrons and
so forth that were perfectly stable in
our universe
brendan says when you write your trade
books do you have a process for
determining the right balance between
being too technical and being too
general
short answer is no and a longer answer
is that every book is different you know
in the biggest ideas series that i'm
writing right now it's pretty technical
like there's a lot of equations in them
the from eternity to here was
was not as technical but it was still
a little bit demanding both in physics
and philosophy whereas uh i think the
big picture
and the higgs boson book
were less demanding in terms of
technicality so sorry i should mention
something deeply hidden on quantum
mechanics
along with from eternity here were both
a little bit demanding in terms of the
concepts being talked about the big
picture and the higgs boson book were a
little bit less demanding but neither
one of them is like quantum mechanics
for babies and they're both involving
some ideas uh that are tough to wrap
your mind around a little bit
i'm very open to the possibility of
someday writing a book that is uh much
less technical or much less demanding
than either one of those books were i
don't know whether that would happen or
not i don't have any immediate plans
maybe the physics of democracy for
example will work out to be that way
i could make that one technical i'm not
sure about that i i hope not i hope
that's not overly technical um i hope to
make it a fun gripping read that's what
i'm always aiming for so it's more about
keeping the level uniform and consistent
within a book rather than making any one
book aim at some imaginary perfect
balance between being too technical and
too general
vladimir bellic says what are some of
the skills that aren't directly related
to science but are very useful to have
for a professional physicist for example
i've been wondering if being a good
salesman or marketer in the broadest
sense of the term could be useful for a
researcher in physics also thank you
very much for the advice you gave
regarding giving talks and being
engaging last ama so i kept that little
lessons in there vladimir because
before i read it i was going to say the
single best advice i could give is learn
to give good talks
it's right up there the second best
advice is learn to write good papers
okay
the basic advice is that there is
science that we do to become a
professional physicist but there's also
telling other people what science we
have done and you'd be surprised at how
often that how important that is you
know both are better and for worse there
are very good examples
of people you know saying something in
such a compelling way that everyone
caught on to it very very quickly there
are also examples where someone had a
good idea and they wrote about it and no
one paid attention and it's not because
that person wasn't famous for other
reasons
i was just looking over the transcript
of the podcast i did a while back with
leonard suskind right he's one of the
co-inventors among other great
accomplishments
lenny's one of the co-inventors of the
holographic principle
the other co-inventor is gerard tuft
another famous nobel prize winning
scientist um sorry lenny's not won the
nobel prize although he's at that level
but but a tuft was one of the single
most important theoretical physicists of
the second half of the 20th century a
huge name in quantum field theory uh
really just revolutionized the field in
the 70s
and lenny tells the story that you know
in some sense in some very real sense
the holographic principle first appeared
in a tufts paper
and suskin wrote another paper about it
not knowing about a tuft's paper second
but no one read etf's paper because the
title of the paper was about dimensional
reduction in quantum gravity and
dimensional reduction has a separate
meaning to physicists and they didn't
think that that was an interesting thing
to read about okay so just because the
title of the paper
was not exactly on point not enough
people read and absorbed and understood
that crucially important point about the
holographic principle at least you know
according to lenny's retelling which i
think
jibes with my uh experiences as a very
young postdoc at the time um so and a
tuft is pretty clear you know often and
he's a very
good writer he's fun to read
and there's many people who are just not
good to read at all or fun to read at
all and that affects whether people are
going to read your papers right likewise
for giving talks some people
you know you always want to go to their
talks even if you're not interested in
subject matter because you know you'll
learn something it'll be fun and other
people
you never want to go to their talks even
though you're super interested in the
subject matter so i think the single
most important thing is communication
and i don't i don't
want to call that being a salesman or
marketer because that's a slightly
different thing um the point of being a
salesman sales person is that you want
someone to buy your goods
that is disconnected from the question
of whether or not your goods are any
good you want people to buy them so what
i'm emphasizing is not selling your
goods but explaining to people what the
goods are let them decide whether or not
they're interesting or not that's what i
think is the most important other skill
flying waffle says aren't super fluidity
and superconductivity examples of strong
emergence i.e to understand those
systems from a macroscopic point of view
we can't just break them down into the
behavior of individual particles so i
know what you mean but no i do not think
that these are examples of strong
immersions and for those who are not
quite following along
the idea of strong emergence is that you
can't just take a microscopic theory
right a theory of the fundamental
constituents of a thing
put it on a computer and let it run that
would be if that
process if that procedure did tell you
always exactly correctly what happened
there might be weak emergence there
might be a way of talking about the
system at a higher level but still the
way of talking about it at the lower
level is complete and comprehensive and
gives you everything that's weak
emergence strong emergence says that you
can't just do that you cannot just take
the microscopic theory simulate it and
get the right answer because something
new comes in at the macroscopic level
so in quantum mechanics the world is not
made up of little things that's just not
how quantum mechanics works at the
fundamental level there is one wave
function for the whole universe and
usually you can get away with ignoring
that or let's say either think of things
as truly separate or separate but
entangled with each other in the
examples of superfluidity and super con
conductivity you can't do that you
really need to take seriously the fact
that there is just one wave function for
the whole system so that might seem to
be
a challenge to the idea of weak
emergence but i think it's a fake
challenge because i think that
most people who think about emergence
are not really familiar enough with
quantum mechanics as they should be
and they make this mistake of conflating
the idea of a microscopic theory
with a theory of microscopic things
to my mind a microscopic theory is just
the more comprehensive theory it's the
it's the theory that works in a wider
domain of applicability including ones
where individual systems are microscopic
but it doesn't necessarily mean that the
system is comprised of little pieces so
i just think that there's a sloppiness
in the way that many people define what
is meant by emergence
if you define it in the conventional way
with little pieces making up big things
no quantum mechanical system counts as
being emergent and you know i think
that's just a mistake because people are
still embedded in a classical way of
thinking
i haven't actually written this up i've
been writing about this for a little
while but i haven't actually completed a
paper or anything uh like that but we're
working on it we're trying to get there
but i think the the fundamental issue of
strong emergence is not about quantum
mechanics versus classical mechanics so
super fluidity and superconductivity
don't really qualify as what the people
who like strong immersions really want
to be talking about
tim kennedy says at the very end of a
black hole evaporating does it explode
in a blaze of glory and if so is it at
all similar to the big bang given there
will be pretty much nothing around it uh
it does explode but it's not much of a
blaze of glory you know the black hole
gets smaller and smaller over a
tremendously long period of time
and as it gets smaller it gets hotter so
its rate of evaporation increases
and you can go down to like the planck
scale right and that's the last burst of
energy is when the black hole is down to
the planck scale and you can calculate
how much energy is given off when a
planck scale thing explodes uh it's not
that much it's like a grenade going off
if i remember it correctly i haven't i
haven't thought about this in a long
time so i might be misremembering but
it's not some big world shattering kind
of thing because most of the energy has
already been transported away much
earlier
eric stromquist says the universe
appears roughly homogeneous and
isotropic reflecting the translational
and rotational symmetries of physics
however the third space-time symmetry of
lorenz symmetry seems observationally
broken
by there being a preferred inertial
frame for example that of the cmb or
even the ordinary matter of the nearby
universe my question is what is the
significance of this and in particular
is the existence of a preferred frame
related to concerns raised about
exactness and fundamentality of lorentz
symmetry i've never seen any doubts
raised about either translational or
rotational symmetry in the laws of
physics
i wanted to answer this question not
because of any great wisdom about it but
because i have written papers about
violating translational and rotational
symmetry uh with mark wise and some
other collaborators uh
lottie ackerman and chen yao zheng we
wrote papers on violating rotational
invariance or translational invariants
during inflation
so how would you see the impact of that
in the cosmic microwave background but i
don't think it's likely that's true we
just we just wanted to figure out this
very common thing to do in physics we
said if it's true how would you know so
now people can go and look in the
microwave background because they
weren't looking before our papers came
out
um but the basic question i think is an
interesting one but i don't have a pithy
answer to it i do think that
it is a fact that our universe seems to
have a preferred
at least approximately preferred rest
frame being at rest with respect to the
cosmic microwave background and in fact
this was an issue in the early days of
inflationary cosmology people pointed
out
that a lot of the models that people
were throwing around had perfect
lorenzen variants during inflation you
know uh basically
something that was desitter space so not
quite lorenzen variants but at least no
preferred rest frame okay sorry about
all the jargon words here but no
preferred rest frame during inflation
and then one somehow got established
when inflation ended and that didn't
quite make sense and the resolute there
is a resolution to this problem and the
resolution is basically that it's not
ever perfectly
uh free of a preferred rest frame there
is always during inflation
some inflaton field doing the inflating
and that field does pick out a preferred
rest frame uh now why was it ever there
that i don't know
that that's a more difficult one uh
it was always there as far as we know so
it's not a matter of you know creating
it such as understanding why it was
always there but i don't think that's a
puzzle that people have really thought
about very carefully so sorry about that
no no helpful answers for that one
john says thanks for answering my
question about positronium during a
previous ama
i have a follow-up during you said that
positronium hydrogen don't have the same
spectrum because of the difference in
mass between a proton and a positron
this must involve gravity right
no has nothing to do with gravity mass
has something to do with gravity that's
true but mass also just has something to
do with inertia right i mean the idea of
mass is there in f equals m a newton's
second law even if the f has nothing to
do with gravity it's just a matter of
the average energies or the total
energies involved in binding two
particles together with different masses
the energies all come from the
electromagnetic force uh
there's a little bit of quantum
mechanical play there but the elect
electromagnetism is the force that is
holding together the proton and the
electron or the positron of the electron
gravity has nothing to do with it
jesse rimler says in the realm of
foreign policy do you agree with the
principle that it is most important for
a citizen to be critical of the actions
of their own state
well i think that's that's a little bit
too vague to be a principle that i agree
with uh
you know most important
in the universe the most important thing
ever written down
maybe what you mean is
it's more important to be critical of
one's own state than of other states i
don't even agree with that what i would
like is just to be correctly critical of
everybody
you know i do think that in practice so
not in principle but in practice one
tends to know more about the pros and
cons of one's own state and i do think
that i mean maybe the implication is you
don't want to give your own state a free
ride just because it's yours that i
agree with yes absolutely but there's no
idea i would not agree with an idea that
until i fix all of my own state's
problems i'm not allowed to criticize
other states i think that's going too
far
frank layman says
what do you make of the academic job
market for recent phds in stem or any
other fields are the woes that come with
it these days reflective of a profound
shift in the prospects for young
scholars or was it ever thus
uh it's always very hard for me to tell
to be very honest about questions like
this there are some numbers and data out
there but there's a lot more feelings
and people's feelings are inevitably
kind of shaped by their own personal
circumstances and what they're familiar
with right and i recognize that and
therefore i'm not gonna i'm gonna try
not to project my own feelings onto
things like that i mean the job market
is not very
good in the sense that there's always
many more people who want to be
professors than there are jobs for
professors so that's true but that's a
weird
kind of thing to complain about i mean
if the job the number of jobs stayed the
same but suddenly overnight twice as
many people wanted those jobs suddenly
the job market is a lot worse but it
doesn't
reflect some flaw in the system or
anything like that i mean the job market
uh for phds is much better than the job
market for nba basketball players
many many many more people want to be
basketball players and would get hired
doing that so i think that's kind of the
wrong way to look at the problem i mean
frank in his in part that i didn't read
of his question he mentions uh
adjuncts and that's a problem this is
for those of you who are not in academia
there's an increasing reliance at many
colleges and universities on not having
the professors teach most of the courses
but not having the full-time professors
teach most of the courses but rather
bringing in part-time adjunct professors
people who don't have tenure who are not
on tenure-track who have no chance of
being promoted or anything like that who
have no time or resources to do research
they're just basically hired guns to
teach a course
and i can imagine that on occasion that
might be a useful thing for university
to do but it's way way overdone in the
current market
i don't worry about the overproduction
of phds
because i think that getting phds is a
good thing
it's an individual choice i think that
people coming into phd programs and
applying for them
should be
told in no uncertain terms what the job
market is like i've gotten flack
actually from my colleagues because
sometimes i'm too honest about the
difficulties of the job market and
they're like no you should be
encouraging the young people and
i don't want to encourage young people i
want to
be honest with the young people if that
encourages them that's great but i'm not
encouraging them for the sake of
encouraging them i want people to know
what the situation really is and the
situation really is that the vast
majority of people who get phds are not
going to become tenured professors
someday
but if they still want to get a phd
knowing that i think that's awesome i
think that's great and we should allow
them to do it so i actually think
there's an overproduction of post docs
if you if you ask me this postdoctoral
thing um if you're a phd student the the
thing you do next is you apply for
postdocs at least in scientific fields
and then eventually you become a faculty
member and that's great if you do
succeed at eventually becoming a faculty
member because it means that you've had
some time to practice and do research
without all the extra burdens of being a
faculty member etc
but very often people don't only just
get a phd but then spend what six nine
ten years as a postdoc and then still
don't get a faculty job and that i think
is much much less justifiable from the
point of view of that researcher because
getting a phd is clearly like i said a
good thing it trains you it gives you
some credential etc
the extra marginal benefit of being a
post-doc for eight years is very tiny in
my mind unless you go on to become a
professor in which case it can be
substantial but for other jobs it's very
tiny so i don't think the problem is
overproduction of phds i think that we
the problem is that we let phds linger
around without giving them permanent
jobs i think that's the problem
carlos nunez says
do you have a specific argument for why
you don't want to have kids are you
familiar with the philosopher david
benitar and if so what's your opinion on
his anti-natalist view benatar argues we
should avoid bringing more people into
this world due to the inherent suffering
of being alive so i think that benatar's
argument is is very wrong from my point
of view i do not think there is inherent
suffering of being alive i kind of think
being alive is pretty awesome it has its
ups and downs but i think that's part of
it being awesome if there weren't downs
we wouldn't appreciate the ups as much
uh to vastly oversimplify a very
complicated set of issues i just don't i
just don't want to have kids that's it
it's not a deep philosophical position i
have other things to do i have other
things that i want to spend my time
doing people some of my best friends
they have kids it's great i don't
actually mind kids as such it's just
that my lifestyle with what i want to do
i would like to put my time and
resources elsewhere i think it would be
terrible to be a parent and then not
spend time spend effort to spend
resources being with your kids and i i
don't really have the resources to do
that myself
justin wolcott says my five-year-old son
nicholas see there's a good kid right
here nicholas i'm sure is an awesome
five-year-old kid
nicholas and his friends at school are
debating whether infinity is the largest
number or not nicholas says it can't be
since it's not a number because infinity
plus one equals infinity ah very good
for nicholas uh but sadly the answer to
this is it depends i mean obviously as
soon as you ask this question right
you're gonna know that the answer is it
depends on what you mean by number right
so there are systems of numbers like the
integers where infinity is not a number
infinity is not an integer because like
you say infinity plus one is not
is still equal to infinity but there are
other systems of numbers that are bigger
than the integers and you can add
infinity and include that in your system
of numbers you have to change a little
bit the rules for what happens when you
add numbers to each other etc but the
point is depending on how you define
number you can accommodate infinity but
you don't have to not a perfectly
satisfying answer but it should inspire
you to go google around different
systems of numbers and how infinity fits
into them joseph williams says do you
think our seemingly advanced
mathematical abilities along with our
appreciation of the beauty and elegance
of math is an involved trait if so why
and how
well in some sense everything is an
evolved trait all of our traits are
evolved right so in that sense sure
uh i would also kind of question the
assumptions of the question i don't
think our mathematical abilities are all
that advanced you know compared to cats
the mathematical abilities of humans are
quite advanced but you know i make
mistakes all the time doing math even in
elementary arithmetic so i'm hesitant to
give myself a lot of credit for advanced
mathematical ability
um i so the real question is is there
some i think what do you mean by the
question is is there some adaptive
advantage to having much more
mathematical ability than a cat has
right or than a chimpanzee well i i tend
to think probably not um i mean there
might be an advantage but i don't think
that
the use of mathematics has arisen
sufficiently long ago
in evolutionary history that that
particular trait was selected for you
know what i mean a lot of things that
we're able to do uh we're able to do
just sort of as a side effect of some of
our um
features or traits or whatever you want
to call them being selected for
completely other reasons so i can easily
imagine that
our brains developed in certain ways and
those developments uh were
evolutionarily advantageous uh and as a
side effect we got better at doing math
i suspect it's more like that i cannot
imagine really that a lot of you know
group theory or differential geometry
was useful to uh hunter-gatherers on the
plains tens of thousands of years ago
richard cashdan says i have a serious
problem with the way people always seem
to talk about simulation theory
the idea that we are living in a
simulated universe they generally say
that the universe is 13 billion years
old and therefore there is plenty of
time for civilizations to grow up to the
point that they can build simulations
and therefore the probability is that we
are in a simulation because there would
be many more simulated universes than
the one original universe i wonder if
you would agree with me this argument is
nonsense because we have no clue how old
the actual universe is
all we would know is that our simulated
universe feeds us signals and clues to
make us made us conclude that if our
universe were real it started with the
big bang some number of years ago what
does that have to do with how and when
the real universe started so there's two
things going on here um one is is it
conceivable or likely
that if we are in a simulation the
simulators have tricked us into thinking
that the universe is 14 billion years
old when it's really not so that is
possible but i think it's not likely and
i'll explain why so it's completely
possible um you could arrange it goes
back to what we were saying about the
low entropy of the big bang vis-a-vis
the smoothness of the cosmic microwave
background right
in some sense what
you're thinking about is the simulators
are tricking us into thinking that there
was a low entropy big bang 14 billion
years ago because the cosmic microwave
background is smooth but they could
easily set up a radiation bath near our
telescopes here that would trick us into
thinking that okay
except even though it's possible it's
not the best way to do it it's not the
simplest or algorithmically
most straightforward way to do it if you
wanted to make us think that the
universe was that old you would just
simulate the whole universe because the
starting point is enormously simpler
right the starting point of a hot big
bang that is smooth and dense and
rapidly expanding that's easy to put
into your computer
all the specific details about the
universe today
in order to match that very simple
beginning are incredibly complicated
you're asking your computer simulator to
do much more work than is necessary if
you want to make them trick us into
thinking the universe is old now maybe
they want to do that it's possible sure
it's possible but i'm just saying that
it's not the sensible way to do it if
you think that our simulators are very
smart then they would just run from the
big bang onward
but more importantly for your actual
question i think that
i i think that your logic is a little
bit uh shaky here richard because
basically what you're saying is
if we live in the simulation
then the universe might not be 14
billion years old sure that's true
but the argument is supposed to be that
if we don't live in a simulation we
could still build a lot of other
simulations and therefore there would
still be a lot of people living in
simulations and then the question comes
about why aren't we one of them right i
don't agree with that argument to be
honest but not for this reason uh
because basically you're already
assuming that we live in a simulation so
they've already won by the standards of
your version of the argument so i i
don't think that that's a good objection
to the simulation argument
casey mahone says sometimes i find it
really odd that i happen to be born
human after all it seems far more likely
that i'd be born a bacteria or an insect
of course the answer said someone had to
be me but that feels unsatisfying can
you offer any insight
uh maybe
so this is actually related to
what i just said is why i don't believe
the real the regular simulation argument
because
there's a presumption a premise of this
kind of reasoning that said that somehow
there is this thing called i
me myself right
that had some probability of being some
thing in the universe and if that
probability was equal with all kinds of
things
then there's a lot more bacteria or
insects than there are human beings i
mean
clearly just by saying it out loud by
spelling it all out i hope the craziness
of that uh chain of reasoning becomes
clear there is no you that that exists
outside your physical body that becomes
embodied in either a bacterium or an
insect or a human being that's just not
the way it works what what happens is
that a lot of bacteria and a lot of
insects a lot of human beings come into
being through the physical evolution of
the universe and the biological
evolution of the species
and there's just no sense in which you
are randomly selected from all possible
living beings why would we ever think
that right um
and this is why i think that a lot of
anthropic reasoning is incorrect
that we
somehow tend to
uh reason as if that were the case but
it really it just it just isn't you're
just you
there's nothing to be explained there
there's no sense in which you could have
been someone other than you someone else
could be someone other than you and in
fact if you took a vote among all the
bacteria and all the insects and all the
human beings in the world which one of
them how many of them are bacteria
they'd be mostly be bacteria that's true
but all the humans would say that
they're human that's just how it works
igor velotek says
in what way has conversation with justin
clark doan affected the way in which you
think about the reality slash
objectivity of mathematics
so yeah i've been continuing to talk to
justin who was on the podcast a little
while ago who's an expert on these
foundations of mathematics questions and
he hasn't convinced me yet i'm not a
mathematical realist i'm a reality
realist i think the physical world
exists and that
mathematics is something that we human
beings use to talk about the physical
world
um i don't want to go into all of the
details but let me just say sort of one
thing that justin keeps saying and one
thing that i keep worrying about
um the thing that justin keeps saying is
it it's not an original argument with
him but it's it's one of the arguments
for mathematical realism is
we need to believe in the consistency of
our theories if you make a statement
like the standard model predicts the
following result
you believe that there are predictions
of the standard model which is to say
that you believe that the theory itself
is consistent it doesn't it doesn't
predict everything if you have an
inconsistent mathematical formalism it
can predict anything so you have to
assume that your systems are consistent
in order to do science etc but making
statements about consistency of theories
is a higher level thing
that you can't prove right and this is a
consequence of girdle's theorem and
subsequent work in mathematics you can't
prove the um consistency of your
theories
uh in fact you could choose to add extra
axioms to sufficiently powerful theories
that either say and this these axiom
system is consistent or and it's not
consistent okay
so the argument is that you have to
accept
in order to believe in the consistency
of your theory you have to accept some
extra non-provable fact
about the theory namely that it is
consistent and since that's not provable
you're basically accepting some
mathematically real fact that just
exists as truth okay um
i don't quite buy that argument because
i don't quite think that
i mean i think i can just assume my
system is consistent and keep using it
without accepting the existence of some
objective fact of the matter outside um
of human invention about whether it is
consistent or not but i'm not 100
certain about that so that's the thing i
wanted to say about my own point of view
is that if i were to criticize myself i
would say that in some sense i want my
cake and eat it too i want to be able to
use math and trust it and think that you
know if people in a completely different
physical reality had invented arithmetic
they would still think that
the twin prime conjecture is either true
or false in that world um where while
still not believing that it's a separate
part of reality right i want the math to
be true but not real and i think that is
a distinction worth drawing but i
couldn't actually promise you that it's
worth drawing so maybe eventually i have
to give in i'm not i'm not sure about
that but i do think that people are
using words like realism and existence
slightly different ways when they talk
about these different things that's
that's the heart of my objection
chris murray says when planning to dine
at a very expensive restaurant how do
you prepare besides dressing for the
occasion are there other steps you take
uh this is a fun question but the answer
is no there's really no other steps that
i take i do think it's nice to dress
nicely when you go to a nice restaurant
but uh
you know some people will try to like
check out the menu online see what is
going on uh other than
sharing some food allergies with the
restaurant ahead of time i'd just like
to show up and uh have no spoilers ahead
of time right see to see what's going to
happen
um you know different restaurants are
very different you know there's some
fine dining restaurants that are
still following the paradigm of
appetizer entree dessert others have
like 20 little tiny courses that are one
bite each and things like that so
there's many ways that the paradigm can
work and that's part of the playfulness
and part of the fun of it some are
very stuffy and formal some are much
more playful etc and you know so i just
like to
wallow in the experience let it happen i
don't i don't do any preparations now
jimmy summer says i was reading a quanta
article and it said that when speaking
about space space-time emerging from
quantum mechanics you could essentially
construct an equivalent theory where
quantum mechanics instead emerges from
space-time so in that construction
space-time is ontological and everything
else is emergent rather than the other
way around and these emergent theories
based on correspondences it would be
difficult to know which way reality is
actually set up does this make any sense
or am i misunderstanding this or is this
just wrong um i'm not exactly sure what
was being referred to in the quantum
article here probably it's referring to
ads cft which is this correspondence
between
uh quantum gravity in anti-descender
space that's ads antidesigner space
and quantum field theory without gravity
in one dimension lower that's the cft
conformal field theory cft and the cft
side of the duality the idea behind the
duality is that these two theories are
supposed to be equivalent to each other
okay um you can start with one and
derive the other or vice versa
but the the fact is the the cft side of
the ledger where there is no gravity is
much easier to define rigorously okay um
and so in practice when you really want
a full description of the theory you
start with the cft and you derive the
quantum gravity side from it as an
emergent holographic phenomenon because
the quantum gravity side has one more
dimension of space-time than the
conformal field theory side does
and i'm not even sure
that the
gravity side by itself
has a full
rigorous description so i'm not quite
sure this really is a duality i'm not a
super expert here but there's been
enough mumblings in talks that i've gone
to and papers i've read to make me a
little suspicious that there's a full
100
super accurate correspondence between
conformal field theories and
anti-dissider space quantum gravity i
think that there's probably a
uh restricted correspondence in the
sense that many emerging descriptions
are right there's a domain of
applicability for them that does not
extend over the complete theory but
anyway
both of these sides of the duality are
quantum mechanical
and both of them also have space time
the difference is that one side has
gravity and the other doesn't okay
so if that is what is being referred to
by the article that you read i would
certainly not say that you derive
quantum mechanics from space-time um you
derive space-time from quantum mechanics
either way that you go uh but maybe i'm
missing it maybe i'm not uh maybe it was
referring to some other idea i don't see
any possible way
that you could get quantum mechanics to
emerge from space time space time is
classical i mean you need when you say
space time you have a theory of what
space time does like einstein's general
relativity or whatever that's a
classical theory you're not going to get
quantum mechanics to emerge from that as
far as i could tell
david de klert says in your recent talk
about the arrow of time this is
referring to the uh talk i gave at
berkeley at the simons institute for the
theory of of computing
it's amazing that i was invited to give
a talk at the simons institute for the
theory of computing giving that i know
nothing about the theory of computing
but there was a workshop there at the
time on causality and i know a tiny bit
about causality much less than most of
the other people there but i know a lot
about the arrow time so i could talk
about the arrow of time and causality
so in this talk david goes on to ask you
mentioned that we believe that entropy
was low in the past because of a very
strong bias in our brains and that
without the past hypothesis it's much
more likely that air molecules randomly
push the wine glass off the desk than
your swinging arm did but now that we
know that we're biased shouldn't we
correct for our bias and choose to
believe whatever we know to be more
likely given that we know we're biased
why we should why should we continue to
believe the past hypothesis
well this is a case where bias is a good
thing because our bias is correct
or our bias is certainly uh yeah our is
just correct let's just let's just put
it that way
and this is an argument i've talked
about it before but it's uh articulated
most clearly in my paper called why
boltzmann brains are bad
the point is that if you didn't have the
past hypothesis
you only had let's grant you
some information about the current
universe you know we could argue in
detail about what you would know and not
know about the current universe if there
were no arrow of time but let's just say
you know the current universe
but there's no past hypothesis so that
you extrapolate
from the current state into both the
past and the future
and the entropy increases in both
directions that's what you would predict
if you didn't have the past hypothesis
but as a result of that what you're
saying is
is that your current moment including
your current self are the results of a
random unlikely fluctuation downward in
entropy from a high entropy past
and that's very possible but what it
means is that the stuff inside your
brain
not only your knowledge of the past but
all of your knowledge of physics and
logic and math and reason
just randomly fluctuated into existence
and it's equally possible for incorrect
ideas to fluctuate into your
brain randomly as for correct ideas in
fact honestly it's way easier to
fluctuate a wrong idea than to fluctuate
a correct idea randomly into your head
so the point being that if you accepted
that past view of the universe if you
accepted that history of our universe
you would have no reason
to accept the past history of the
universe because you would have no
reason to accept your own views on
anything at all
so this is cognitively unstable this
point of view this is a point of view
which you cannot simultaneously hold and
believe you have good reason for holding
because
in virtue of holding that view you
shouldn't believe that view okay so
therefore the way to get out of it is
just to say i don't believe that view
you can say look maybe it's true just
like maybe we're a brain in a vet or
being taunted by an evil demon like any
other skeptical hypothesis but it's no
way to go through life in order to
have a view of the universe that makes
sense and makes it possible to make
progress etc you have to assume the past
hypothesis and then you check it you say
okay i assume that the entropy was low
in the early universe and then you look
at our maps of the microwave background
and so forth and you go yes this is
consistent with that assumption i made i
think i'm on the right track that's how
it works
rue phillips says can you please expand
on the meaning of it from bit that john
archbord
john archibald wheeler said decades ago
chalmers seems to take it quite
literally in his latest book on virtual
worlds what's the real insight here and
how speculative is it
well
i don't know
it's the short answer uh john wheeler
famously was better at coining
pithy provocative phrases than at
spelling out all the details of the
implications for these phrases um so it
from bit is probably
his uh most inscrutable
phrase uh in some sense what it's
supposed to mean
is that information is key to
understanding what happens in the
universe rather than thinking of the
world as just stuff it right bumping
into each other
think about the information contained in
that stuff and the implication would be
that if you had
very different stuff
but following the same pattern
containing the same information
uh standing in the same relation to
other stuff in the universe etc then it
would for all intents and purposes
qualify as the same thing
going on okay so a down-to-earth way of
saying this is the substrate
independence of consciousness or
cognition it doesn't matter in this
point of view if it's in a computer or
in a brain or whatever if the same kinds
of information processing events are
happening they are equivalent to each
other so
it's not
you know a principle that you can test
or anything like that it's a perspective
that you can take on what is going on in
the world so you can take it quite
literally or not i mean i think that
if you're careful
uh there are both differences and
similarities between what happens in a
biological brain and what happens in the
computer for some purposes the
differences will matter for some they
will not and i'm not trying to dismiss
the question i think these are very
important questions but i think that a
pithy slogan is not going to be the
final word on those
questions brian tidmore says my 12 year
old son has stated that he wants to
invent teleportation
i explained to him why it's impossible
delved a little into the physics of what
we know of matter and how the universe
has rules but i felt my answer was
discouraging him what are your thoughts
on encouraging creativity and interest
in science but keeping a young mind
grounded in reality
this is a great question and you know it
doesn't stop when your son is 12 years
old it works with graduate students and
postdocs and even colleagues and maybe
even yourself
going on that line between
explaining why something doesn't sound
to you like a good idea
while still encouraging them to try i
mean i think everyone certainly i
uh everyone who's gone up through
theoretical physics has had a this
experience of having an idea
taking it to some wiser elder person
running it by them and being told why it
wouldn't work and believing them and
going away and then realizing either
because you figured it out or because
someone else scooped you on it that it
would have worked if you had just tried
harder on it
so in my own
role sometimes as an advisor or
something um i try to
have exactly this balance between saying
well you know here's the problems with
that idea but i don't want to discourage
you um
and then sometimes you just got to
discourage them because the idea is so
obviously wrong that you think it's not
worth it and that's a risk this is just
the risk of doing science but okay at
the level of talking to um a 12 year old
you know
for one thing
are you sure the teleportation is
impossible
you know i i get that there are very
good arguments for it how well do we
know that those arguments are true how
do well we know that energy is conserved
or that
information cannot travel faster than
the speed of light these are things that
we know that we that we think we know
and in fact i think that they're
probably true and some construal of them
but
you can ask how well we know why do we
know right
um
and also you can sort of steer from the
original idea to a related idea like
okay why do you want to invent
teleportation what's important about
that
given the constraints of physics as we
currently understand it maybe the
original idea didn't work but maybe
there's some other idea that does the
job just as well or is more interesting
you can explain that okay here's what we
are able to do here's what people are
thinking about now you know here are
ways to get around very fast from place
to place you can talk about wormholes
for example
you could talk about quantum
teleportation all the things you can
just google i'm not going to explain
them all right now but you could say
look there are things we think we
understand quite well there are things
that we don't understand nearly as well
sometimes it's a little tricky
to clearly discern the boundary between
them and so you know encourage
him to go look it up and and think about
it and the other thing is that this is
just inevitable and i don't know any way
around this
to really understand what's going on in
these issues right deeply into the heart
of physics it's it takes time it takes a
lot of work it takes a lot of
prerequisites where you have to learn
things and a lot of math is involved and
that can be really discouraging when
you're 12 years old you want to skip to
the answer you don't want to learn
differential geometry and quantum field
theory you want to know why you can't
build a teleportation device and that's
very very very frustrating
at some level you just have to be honest
and say sorry you have to learn all this
stuff at the other level you can say
look the good news is there's all this
stuff that you get to learn and other
people have already figured it out so
you don't have to invent it for yourself
you can just learn it and that's
possible to do and it will take time but
it's enormously fun and rewarding to do
that so you have to preach preach a
little patience
you have to look for the chinks in the
armor of what you think is true and you
have to encourage uh people to really
think through the ways in which their
crazy ideas may or may not work
and then you know it's
there's a crucial divergence at some
point in a young person's life where
they decide to become a scientist
and really think about things and give
up on some favorite ideas when they
don't work out but still keep working on
others if they're promising or they
become a crackpot
and the difference is that the crackpots
don't listen and learn the crackpots
have zero interest
in learning from you they think they
know the answer already and they just
want to tell you and that's what you
want to avoid
letting your children become don't mama
don't let your babies grow up to be
crackpots
encourage them to keep learning
to accept that their ideas might not be
right but maybe they can make them
better by working on them learning more
and listening to others and thinking
about it all
the quintas mork venus says do you have
any handcraft hobbies uh no it's the
short answer um i don't even have that
many hobbies i don't know what counts as
a hobby you know a lot of my time is
spent either thinking or talking or
writing about
physics and philosophy and other ideas
out there in the world and i like it
that way you know i'm not going to
apologize for that i'm very very
fortunate to be in a situation where i
can do this uh an enormous amount of my
energy goes into doing it and i get paid
to do it it's my job i have a job title
you know
um so no complaints about that but not a
lot of time do i spend on you know
puttering around building things or
whatever um
i i have painted in the past i was never
any good at that uh as i mentioned
earlier uh on the podcast i bought a
bass guitar during the pandemic uh i
still have every plan to learn that but
it's been slowed down by other
obligations maybe after i move to
baltimore we'll have a music room who
knows but building things or creating
things or
you know quilting or crocheting and
things like that no i've never really
taken that up um
let a thousand flowers bloom let people
do different things i love it when
people do it so but i can't offer any
wisdom from my own perspective
ray fuchillow says
doesn't the holographic principle place
an upper bound on the size of the
universe i've heard you say the universe
may be infinite but it seems that at
some large size there'd be insufficient
space on the boundary to account for the
density of information that we observe
around us since the surface-to-volume
ratio decreases with size
so no not not quite uh the trick is that
there's less information around us than
you think so the holographic principle
says that if i have a region of space
and i surround it by a boundary
the amount of information inside the
region the amount of information
characterizing the region itself
uh can be encoded or is no greater than
the area of the boundary as measured in
plank units
so you don't need a very big region
before there are far fewer planck units
on the boundary than there are planck
volumes in the region okay but the point
is of the holographic principle that
what is happening in all those
parts of the region of space is not
independent
what's going on in one region is sort of
redundantly encoded with what's going on
in other regions that's the only reason
holography is possible now
you have to understand that the plank
length the plank volume the plank area
these are really really tiny so you can
fit a lot of information
on a plank size boundary surface around
you so the limitations of doing that in
terms of what you see around you
literally like planets and stars and
galaxies that is nowhere close to
saturating the amount of information
that you can encode on the boundary
according to the holographic principle
um raphael busso has you know nicely
formulated the holographic principle in
a completely rigorous way
and it works differently in different
kinds of cosmological space times uh if
you if you have a sufficiently rapidly
expanding universe then there's sort of
no limit to the amount of information
you can put on because it's really not
when you technically go into it it's not
about the area of the boundary it's
about the well sorry it is the
relationship is not between the area of
the boundary and the information inside
it's between the area of the boundary
and the information that ultimately
flows through the future light cone of
that region but the future like home can
be infinitely big if you live in an
expanding universe of the right form so
there's tricky subtleties there but
anyway uh the short answer is no there's
no upper bound on the size of the
universe in minkowski space where
there's no expansion of the universe
it can be infinitely big holographic
principle can still apply no problem
jonathan goodson says when i see two
particles exchange a photon on a fineman
diagram it looks like it's a simple
matter for the photon to find the target
particle but given their size their
spatial separation and the fact that the
photon could be emitted in any direction
the exchange seems extraordinarily
unlikely is the photons trajectory
constrained by an electromagnetic field
and if not how do we
account for its incredible navigation
skills
so yeah in in that first question you're
sort of uh you're almost there in
getting the right answer
remember
the world is not made of particles the
world is made of fields so particles are
a convenient way to talk about what we
see when we observe the quantum fields a
tiny fluctuation vibration in the field
looks like a particle and even better
feynman discovered that we can talk
about the interactions between the
fields in terms of an infinite number of
particles that we're summing over so
when you see that image in a fineman
diagram of a particle being exchanged
between two different particles a
virtual particle right that's a
shorthand for vibrations in the fields
and the fields are everywhere the
particles look like they live on some
line on some world line traveling from
one place to another but it's a
representation of what is actually
happening in the field and the field is
everywhere so the field doesn't have to
find the target particle every little
vibration in one field is sort of
sympathetically causing vibrations in
all the other fields and all of their
combined feedbacks
lead to these interactions that you're
talking about so you just have to keep
in mind that finding diagrams are just
shorthand for what quantum fields are
actually doing
kunal menda says how do you envision the
many worlds interpretation winning out
will it forever be an argument based on
parsimony or are there any experimental
findings that might help us
well i think both you know i mean i
think that many worlds is both simple
and it fits the data and if that
continues then it will look good for
many worlds but there's two other things
that will happen
one is that there's also the the
question of fruitfulness uh you know
thomas kuhn long after he had done his
famous book the structure of scientific
revolutions where he talked about
paradigm shifts and so forth he was
accused of being a relativist about
scientific truth and he wasn't so he
he explained in a later paper that no
there's there's absolutely criteria that
we use to choose between scientific
theories the problem is that the
criteria are not quite an algorithm
there's different criteria that weigh
differently and one of them is the
fruitfulness of an idea so i think that
what will really cause people to get on
the many worlds bandwagon is when you
can make some money with many worlds
when you can use that perspective to
understand other puzzles in physics like
quantum gravity for example so that's
exactly what i am trying to do so if you
show that the many worlds perspective is
really really useful i mean arguably it
helped lead to the mention of quantum
computers with david deutsch and others
so that's already a useful
version of it but if you can keep
showing that it is uh the most
productive way of thinking about quantum
mechanics then people will begin to
accept it more but on the question of
experimental findings you know that's
where you're going to be able to
distinguish between
many worlds and other competitors
like pilot wave theories or whatever
well it's not the only way i i suspect
that other versions of quantum mechanics
just don't make sense ultimately
pilotwave theories or objective collapse
theories i think that they're ultimately
ill-defined especially in the context of
quantum gravity they always help
themselves to some pre-existing
classical notion of location and space
and things like that which won't be
appropriate once you quantize gravity so
support for those alternatives might
just wither away anyway
but i would love to be able to find
experimental differences there are
obvious experimental differences between
many worlds and objective collapse
theories and those experiments are
ongoing people are looking for evidence
of objective collapses they haven't
found any yet but who knows eventually
hopefully they'll they will be able to
rule out all of the promising models
for pilot wave theories there is this
idea there's a claim
that there are no differences in the
predictions between pilot wave theories
and many worlds i'm a little skeptical
of that claim you know it's a theorem
that you can prove but like any theorem
there are assumptions that you make that
go into that theorem and i'm a little
skeptical of the assumptions so i would
love to develop an actual killer here is
the experiment you can do to distinguish
between many worlds and pilot wave
theories but i haven't done it yet so
i'm not sure whether it's possible or
not
now i'm going to group two questions
together
one is from charles miro and it's a
priority question and he asks if each
semi-classical branch of the wave
function instantiates a different real
universe within its own space time it
seems that for non-interaction between
the branches both space and time must be
emergent from the quantum formalism but
this doesn't seem to be the case also
it's hard to understand how decoherence
can create new space times because it is
it is a dynamical phenomenon that
spreads outward in a light cone within
the present space time so the question
is how is this possible the dynamical
present process of decoherence creating
different non-interacting space times
and paul torek says can you sketch an
outline of how ever-ready in quantum
mechanics leads to each branch having
its own space-time i.e one that lacks
any curvature that would be due to
massive objects in the other branches
so
yeah i am someone who believes that when
you have an everettian branching of the
worlds
each world has its own spacetime and
one sort of question that is lurking in
the background here is what do you mean
by
a space-time so i think there's two
different ways you could slice it you
know and the the point of space time is
that it has a metric
there's a metric on space time that
tells you where the light cones are what
the curvature is what distances are all
of that stuff right that's the geometry
of a space time is encoded in the metric
so if you wanted to
you could say there is only one space
time but there are two different metrics
right so let's imagine you do something
like an experiment where because dawn
page has actually done this experiment
you know just for fun he said you know
let's take a geiger counter or you know
let's take some i don't know exactly
what he used to use some quantum
measurement device that can give you two
different answers up or down left to
right or whatever and if it's one answer
he takes a bowling ball and moves it to
the left and he takes if it's the other
answer he takes a bowling ball moves it
to the right and then use a cavendish
experiment which measures the
gravitational field of a nearby object
to say you know did the gravitational
field follow the bowling ball and of
course the answer is that the
gravitational field followed the bowling
ball exactly as it would if the world
were just classical right
and if you thought that somehow the
gravitational field of the bowling ball
in the other branch of the universe
could still be felt in your branch that
should not happen you should observe a
gravitational field that was halfway in
between the two bowling balls okay now
no one expects that to happen but that
would be what you should expect if you
think that the force of gravity in one
could leak into the other branch
but if you think of it in terms of
the metric the metric defining the
curvature of space-time the metric is
just another field just like the
electromagnetic field or the electron
field or whatever so it's conceptually
not hard at all
to imagine that there are two branches
with two different metrics on them right
and what we would call that is
two different space times because
space-time is defined by what the metric
is doing but it's not that conceptually
difficult so in charles's question i
think i would like to undo a lot of the
assumptions here um
number one space and time can be
emergent from the quantum formalism some
of us like myself have written papers
saying exactly that so i think that
that's pretty straightforward we don't
know that it's true in any obvious way
but it's certainly possible certainly
conceivable i happen to think it's very
promising
and then also you say decoherence is a
dynamical phenomenon that spreads
outward in a light cone within the
parent space-time
that's not true either
that is an option that you have in
everybody in quantum mechanics how to
define the splittings of
the universe whether or not you want to
localize it inside a light cone or
whether or not you just want to say
in some frame that you choose you
describe splitting as happening
instantaneously in that reference frame
either way of doing it is perfectly
legitimate gives all the same
experimental predictions etc etc so
branches of the wave function are like
are a higher level immersion phenomenon
okay they are like entropy or
temperature or things like that they are
not something that exists at the
fundamental level they are
higher level constructions that are
useful for human beings to talk about um
it's human beings who clear care about
the classical limit it's not the
universe that cares about the classical
limit so we can choose we're given this
option in many worlds to define
branching as either being confined to a
light cone or being instantaneous
john eastman asks a priority question i
accelerate charged particle a causing
virtual photons to travel to distant
charged particle b
which feels a force proportional to a's
acceleration
is there an inertia-like reaction force
acting back on particle a could a weak
field gravity analog of this effect
explain inertia itself
i'm sorry i know there's a priority
question but i think that the the words
are a little bit too vague for me to
understand what is being asked i don't
know what an inertia-like reaction force
is supposed to be
um it is true that there are radiation
reaction forces for all uh long-range
forces which i guess basically is e m
and gravity namely um when you
accelerate a particle that has charge or
mass then the field around it responds
and that changes what you might naively
think would be the acceleration of the
original particle
it doesn't really affect
it doesn't really depend on whether or
not there is another particle charged
particle b far away this radiation
reaction effect can happen just with one
particle in the universe if you have
other particles then there will be other
forces going on yes indeed uh how
however i would say that none of this
explains inertia itself it's an extra
tiny little correction onto the fact
that there is inertia and also i don't
know why you want to explain inertia
inertia is just a fact about the
universe f equals m a in the newtonian
limit um you know at some point you say
this is how the world works and you
don't try to explain it or if you if you
really are devoted to explaining an idea
what you really have to do is imagine
that the idea was wrong
right so you don't just say i would like
to explain inertia you say i would like
to compare two different universes one
of which has the notion of inertia in it
and one of which does not these are two
different hypothetical universes and
that now i will explain why we seem to
live in one rather than the other that
is a sensible program to undertake and i
don't think the radiation reaction has
any impact on either one of them
paul hardy says i watched a discussion
on entanglement and they suggested that
entanglement could be closely related to
the creation of space so space isn't
fundamental would this mean that our
entanglement might play a crucial role
the big bang when our universe was
created um yeah possibly i mean as i
mentioned i've written papers on space
arising from quantum entanglement and i
did write one paper with collaborators
called quantum circuit cosmology where
we talked about how the expansion of
space you know in in a view where
space
is an emergent feature of a bunch of
entangled quantum degrees of freedom
then the how what does it mean for space
to expand well it means that more
degrees of freedom are becoming
entangled so we have this picture where
you start with a large number of
unentangled qubits or other quantum
degrees of freedom and you have a
quantum circuit that describes how those
unentangled qubits become entangled with
the rest of the world and now become
part of space-time and if you play that
movie backwards you reach a point
because of the holographic principle
there's only a finite number of qubits
in our current universe
so if the number of qubits is increasing
as time goes on it was decreasing in the
past
and you reach a point where there is the
first pair of entangled qubits
and it's basically at the beginning of
inflation in our picture that we wrote
about um so in some sense
it's not the big bang you know i wanna
maybe i should have started this answer
by saying that what do you mean by the
big bang
the big bang
of course there's a difference between
the big bang model which is just a hot
expanding universe that we live in and
that's true there's also the big bang
event the singularity at the beginning
of the cosmos that doesn't exist there
is no singularity at the beginning of
the cosmos okay that is a prediction of
classical general relativity but
classical general relativity is not
right
so
it's a stand-in for whatever happened at
that moment okay it's not a singularity
uh so in this picture what happened at
that moment the first thing that
happened in our universe
was two qubits became entangled
now why did that start why did that
happen what happened before that were
they just unentangled forever or what's
going on all very good questions none of
which we tried to answer in our paper in
that particular paper i tried to answer
them in other papers uh but we don't
know so
to your direct question
would this mean entanglement might play
a crucial role at the big bang sure
it's completely possible but we don't
know this is all very speculative right
now
anders hansen says quantum
electrodynamics qed is considered to be
one of the most accurate theories in the
history of science however there are
opinions about it that it is wrong in
different aspects what is your option
and our opinion and why
um
so i'm not sure the sense in which you
mean that it is wrong it's a little
vague to say their opinions that it is
wrong i'm not quite sure what that
refers to
it's clearly wrong in that it's
incomplete right there are particles
other than the ones that are described
in qed
strictly speaking um qed is the theory
of photons electrons and positrons and
that's it right electrons anti-electrons
and the photons that give forces between
them that's the original definition of
qed so if you believe there are
neutrinos and quarks if you believe
there's a strong interactions in the
weak interactions then qed is wrong but
really we don't usually say it's wrong
we say that it's just part of a bigger
structure electromagnetism has become
unified with the weak interactions and
the electroweak theory
we also know there are the strong
interactions and and so on maybe all
three of those forces are unified in
grand unification but we just don't know
right now
there's another sense a much more subtle
and interesting sense in which qed might
be wrong
when we understood finally you know it
was until the 1970s we really understood
quantum field theory
and part of that understanding was
renormalization group flow so
renormalization
has this this uh reputation as being
about hiding infinities okay and it was
originally that was in the 40s and 50s
the idea that we had infinities in
quantum field theory we had to get rid
of them we renormalized them but it was
understood much better through the work
of wilson and previously uh gelman and
lowe and kadanov and others
in the 60s and 70s where we understood
that renormalization is really a way of
looking at physics at different scales
including the effects of different
processes at different energy and time
and length scales so what wilson in
particular was able to show is that you
can take a quantum field theory and cut
it off
you can say i'm just not going to
include
effects above a certain energy scale and
because energy is inversely proportional
to length that's like i'm not including
effects below a certain wavelength and
you might say well who chooses that
wavelength like that that sounds
important you're just arbitrarily
cutting off your quantum field theory
and the renormalization group
is a way of dealing with that of saying
i can
choose whatever cutoff i want
to not include uh processes of very high
energies
and by letting the other parameters of
my theory change with respect to that
cut off
so the mass of the electron and the
amount the charges of different
particles all these things depend on the
cutoff i can make everything vary
together in such a way that my low
energy predictions remain unchanged
that's the normalization group so when
we finally figured out that
there was a feature of qcd of the strong
interactions that which is that it is
asymptotically free that at higher
energies the interaction becomes weaker
and weaker
that was good that was that made qcd our
best defined theory of fundamental
physics because
all of the problematic aspects of qcd uh
of of any quantum field theory the
problem problematic aspects are always
at high energies and in qcd the
interactions turn off at high energy so
it's really not problematic at all
qed
is not perfectly well defined at high
energies and there is in fact a very
subtle kind of blowing up singularity
called the landau pole of qed and it's
very very much higher energy than the
planck scale it's not anything you have
to worry about in practice but it is a
a sign that you can't just take qed and
extend it to arbitrarily high energies
or short wavelengths maybe that is what
was meant by
qed being wrong you can cure that by
embedding qed in a bigger framework i
don't think the standard model is
sufficient because there's still that u1
in su-3 across su-2 cross u1 that u1 is
basically an electromagnetism-like
theory but if you embed it in a grand
unified gauge group then you can solve
that land outpul problem so
qed is certainly right for describing
what goes on in computers and in your
biology even if it's not right at these
super duper high energies
cecar rabbala says it is fair to say
that you are quite successful outside of
physics and academia did you think of
quitting academia and research before
you moved to johns hopkins university is
your motivation and drive to do physics
academia research the same say as it was
10 years ago
uh yeah i'd thought about
quitting academia but i'd not thought
about quitting research research is the
thing that makes me the happiest it
keeps me the most intellectually engaged
and i have a million ideas of things i
want to do research-wise so if anything
the drive to do research is higher now
than it was 10 or 20 years ago i mean i
always sort of abstractly loved doing
research and thinking about the universe
but i think now i have a much better
idea than i did decades ago about where
the interesting questions are and how i
can make progress answering them so if i
was going to leave academia it was so
that i could do more research or and the
research of the kind that i precisely
wanted the reason why i'm going to
hopkins other than the fact that they
offered me the job was because it's a
job that is suited to let me do that to
let me do exactly the kind of research i
want to do with the people i want to do
it with etc so
it's worked out very very well that way
i'm not going to stop doing the
non-academic stuff that that'll still go
on
tyler whitmer says you're really good at
remembering former guests and
cross-referencing them on the fly when
topics overlap with your current guest
do you have a cheat sheet or something
or just a really good memory
i think that i neither i certainly don't
have a cheat sheet and i don't have a
good memory either in fact i think it's
the opposite uh it's interesting that it
is often the case that i don't remember
interesting tidbits of former podcasts
because while i'm podcasting well i'm
you know the questioner
live there with the uh guest i'm
thinking about what question comes next
do i hit the record button how is the
sound quality how much time is left all
of these things right and
i try to make it also seem like a real
conversation like i'm not just listing i
don't have a pre-listed set of questions
to ask i'm trying to respond mostly
to what the person just said there's
some talking points that i want to reach
there's some things i want to get to so
i might sometimes change the topic for
that reason but usually i'm just trying
to actually
act like it's a conversation and ask
questions uh but of course i do some
preparation for each episode which
involves you know reading or listening
or whatever and while doing that i might
be reminded of previous podcasts the
thing is that for a podcast like this
i'm the one inviting the guests right i
mean that's the difference between this
and a talk show on radio or tv where
someone books the guests and some
different person asks them the questions
so if i'm inviting someone on the
podcast it's because i'm interested in
what they have to say for some
pre-existing reason so i'm not just you
know thinking well this is the question
i'm supposed to ask i'm thinking this is
the issue i want the answer to and often
those are connected with previous
podcasts that i often also had issues i
wanted the answer to so to me it all
does kind of fit together in a way so
it's not a matter of having a really
good memory it's a matter of having
reasons why previous guests were there
and relating them to what the current
guest is saying
jason warrell asks is the bigger motive
for physics mainly to comprehend the
place of humanity in the vast cosmos or
is it mainly to advance the place of
humanity in the vast cosmos i don't
think that there is a bigger motive
honestly i'm not sure that's a
competition that there's going to win
different physicists will have different
reasons and different people will have
different reasons my own
interest is mostly in understanding and
comprehending uh the cosmos i'm very
interested in advancing the place of
humanity making the world a better place
both here on earth and in the cosmos but
i do have this conviction two
convictions number one that advancing
humanity
is easier when you understand the world
in which you live and number two there
should be an ecosystem a balance between
people who are purely trying to make
things better and advance humanity and
people who are trying to lay the
groundwork for doing that in a more
comprehensive way down the road i think
that my skill set and my interests are
more
aligned with the understanding big
picture kinds of questions than with
advancing this particular local issue
right now jeff b says occasionally when
i study physics i can feel my woo-woo
side longing to break free as much as i
want to understand the truth of the
universe another part of me wishes that
we lived in a world with angels demons
and gods that play tricks do you ever
have this wish and are you ever able to
satisfy it through fiction
well you know i did have that wish uh
when i was younger and i was very much
interested in science fiction and
fantasy and movies and comic books and
things like that and even you know it
strikes me now that comic book
characters are movie stars that the
comic book characters that i liked
when i was a kid in comic book age was
um were the ones who were most
supernatural in some sense the most
cosmic the most spooky um
uh doctor strange green lantern thor
were much more interesting to me than
batman and superman and spider-man ever
were so and i think the same thing you
know remains true except now that i know
that it is purely through fiction you
know when i was a kid i was very
interested in parapsychology and esp and
telekinesis and ufos and all that stuff
now i know more about the world and i
think the chances that any of that are
real are very very tiny um and so that's
okay i am very happy to tickle that itch
scratch that itch you don't want to
tickle image to scratch that itch
through uh fiction of various sorts and
by the way i just realized i said comic
book reading age what i meant by mike
what i meant by that was my comic book
reading age people of all ages are very
very welcome to read comic books i still
do it myself sometimes as an indulgence
but when i was a kid i was into it i
knew what was going on these days i had
no idea what's going on in comic book
land
speaker ukraine says to explain science
to people scientists often dumb it down
using approximations and analogies
people take these simplifications at
face value and build crazy theories
around them arriving to crazy or at
least false conclusions how would you
dissuade any conspiracy theorists of
their being wrong sometimes you have to
challenge them anyway as they are
decision makers or influencers etc
well i think
there's two things that are being
smushed together here that maybe i'm not
quite willing to smush together
yes scientists absolutely simplify they
use approximations and analogies and yes
it is absolutely a danger that people
can listen and hear the analogy
perfectly
but then
presume that parts of the analogy that
weren't meant to be taken seriously
should be taken seriously and therefore
end up
misunderstanding some delicate nuanced
scientific point that is absolutely a
danger i think that it is something
where that's something that people have
to watch out for because scientists know
when they're using an analogy which
parts of the analogy are real and which
parts are not the person listening might
not know that that's why i'm very much
against things like the balloon analogy
for the expanding universe right because
we know as scientists that there's no
inside the balloon or outside the
balloon there's just the surface of the
balloon but the people who you're
showing that analogy to have trouble
appreciating what that really means so i
just don't use it i just use like
expanding raisin bread or something
something where it's three-dimensional
from the start
the other thing you're asking about are
like conspiracy theorists and decision
makers and i i do not think
that people become conspiracy theorists
because they listen to scientists
explain things and take the
simplifications too literally i don't
think that's why you become a conspiracy
theorist um
i don't know i don't have a fully uh
fledged out theory of why people do
become conspiracy theorists i encourage
everyone to listen to the podcast
with uh t wen
uh who really has a wonderful theory of
the uh valorization of clarity you know
conspiracy theorists like the fact that
their conspiracy
provides an answer to everything and it
provides an answer that is crisp and
clear and uh immediately understandable
and black and white and rigorous and the
world is not the world is a mess the
world has things we don't understand etc
and so a real correct understanding of
the world is less complete than a good
conspiracy is and i don't know the way
to talk conspiracy theorists out of
their conspiracy theorizing but one
thing to point out is you have to be
willing to accept uh ambiguity and
uncertainty in your decision in your
picture of the world and also the other
thing to point out is
one problem with conspiracies is that
they often don't really think through
how they were going to happen um they
they sort of imagine actors with
infinite superpowers
pushing things around out there in the
world whereas really it's people you
know all these people with their own
flaws and their own hopes and their own
ways of working and there's some
collective emergent behavior that comes
out of all of that and it's very hard to
imagine a small cabal of ultra powerful
people pushing around the world in any
realistic kind of way i don't know if
pointing that out actually changes the
minds of any conspiracy theorists but i
think that's a real reason to not be a
conspiracy theorist yourself
dipankar bose says
in our universe all matter and thus all
life forms including us are made up the
first generation of particles in the
standard model that is to say i'm this
is me now talking um electrons electron
neutrinos up quarks and down quarks and
of course the up and downs make protons
and neutrons so that's the first
generation of particles the next
generation is muons and they're
neutrinos charmed in strange quarks the
third generation is taus and they're
neutrinos top and bottom quarks and all
those heavier particles just decay away
leaving us with the first generation so
anyway resuming the question i was
trying to imagine some other universe
that has matter and life made of
entirely of particles from the second or
third generation is this possible or
does the question not even make sense
because the standard model only applies
to our universe
well no i think the question makes sense
no sorry i don't think the question
makes sense but not because the standard
model only applies to our universe i
think it's perfectly sensible to ask if
we didn't have the standard model but
something like it but slightly different
how would the universe be different
that's a perfectly sensible
counterfactual question to ask the
problem is that by definition
the second and third generation is made
of the heavier particles right so very
similarly to if we define the past to be
the direction which entropy was lower
exposed facto we define the first
generation of particles to be the
particles that are the lightest and it's
just a feature of quantum field theory
that heavy particles decay into light
ones why do they do that ultimately it's
because entropy increases
because when a heavy particle decays
into light particles it decays into
several particles right one particle
cannot decay into one particle
if the two particles had different
masses without conserving energy so when
the neutron decays for example it decays
into a proton plus
an electron a neutrino and an
anti-neutrino so there's more particles
and therefore more entropy you can
imagine a process by which several
particles come together several light
particles come together to make a
heavier one but that would decrease the
entropy of the universe because there
would be fewer particles sometimes it
happens but the overall tendency is for
heavier to decay into light so anyway
the answer is in whatever universe
you're in if that universe obeys the
laws of quantum field theory and has an
ordinary arrow of time
you're going to make
whatever matter you have out of the
stable light particles so if you think
about it i talked about this in the
biggest ideas in the universe in the
video about
either atom i think it's atoms that that
video um
basically all the particles there's many
many many particles in the standard
model they're all produced in the early
universe but they all decay until you
hit the lightest set of particles that
contain some conserved quantity so
neutrinos are just the lightest
particles period
uh the lightest particles with with the
light is fermions okay let's let's put
it that way massless particles like
photons are of course lighter but you
can't turn a fermion into a boson
uh electrons are the lightest particles
with charge protons are the lightest
particles with baryon number and so
forth neutrons are not the lightest
particles with anything but neutrons are
also not stable they decay when you
combine
neutrons with protons you can make
metastable nuclei that's what atoms are
made out of
jim murphy says were you a gifted
student in grade school and do you think
that the us school system does a good
job good enough job at helping these
students reach their full potential
i was i was a gifted student i was in
the gifted classes
in fact i was a student when that idea
of having gifted classes first came into
existence i remember very vividly that
when the
idea first happened in my local
pennsylvania public school system they
had no idea what to do and we kind of
did arts and crafts
for a year as gifted students but
eventually
it just turned into you know
advanced courses and the same kind of
thing we had you know gifted english
gifted math or whatever um it was sort
of a they
in principle you know why the letter of
the law did what the mandates had to do
but it wasn't anything special
do they do a good enough job at helping
these students reach their full
potential no of course not but the same
thing is true for not gifted students or
for average students or for any students
the us system as i know it does not do a
good enough job at helping students
reach their full potential
and different so i i don't think of it
as in terms of you know gifted versus
non-gifted all students are different
and we can't invent a new educational
system anew for each student therefore
it will always be the case that whatever
the system is is going to make
compromises to try to optimize teaching
as many students as it can as well as it
can
so some students are going to not get as
much out of that as other students and
that's a shame and we should try to do
it better i don't think any students are
fully served by the current system
especially because some students will
have secret talents right we'll be you
know very bad at taking whatever
standardized test you're using but
really good at something else and the
system is not
built to really uh find those talents
and encourage them it sort of bulldozes
you into a certain way of being which is
not the ideal thing i don't know how to
fix it either though so you know there's
one thing to complain about it there's
another thing to to try to make it
better
brandon lewis says what is your favorite
subset of mathematical notation and what
is the least and how is the notation you
use regularly evolved over the course of
your career
uh
this is a funny question but that's why
i took it because i had not really
thought about it the you know the short
answer for favorite mathematical
notation is tensor notation in general
relativity and i've always had like a
pet theory for why it is so good namely
the general relativity was kind of
useless for a long time einstein
invented it in 1915 and it didn't really
become heavily used
in astrophysics until relatively
recently you know the number of nobel
prizes that uh lean heavily on general
relativity was very tiny it was like one
before the year 1980 and it's it's like
half of them in the most recent 10 or 15
years so general relativity has finally
become really really important
so basically and again pet theory i have
no idea if this is true or not i think
that the physicists who did care about
general relativity during the early days
had enough time to like really make the
notation really good and agree on what
they what they said whereas in quantum
mechanics and quantum field theory they
were so busy leaping to the next puzzle
and trying to solve it that they never
had good time to figure out what the
good notation was so that is my story
i'm not necessarily sticking to it but
that's what i think is true
richard graf says in your podcast with
nicole younger halpern on quantum
steampunk thermodynamics she described
how information could perform work
compared to a classical example like a
sparked fuel moving a piston the
steampunk example appears less direct
it's not so much the knowledge that
moves the weight as what the
experimenter does with that knowledge
and the effort required of the
experimenter requires additional work
input that seems more directly tied to
the weight movement than the knowledge
does have i tangled myself up in too
much nuance here and if so can you help
untangle and clarify
well i can try to explain what is going
on so
in some sense i i don't think let's put
it this way
information and its role in physics is
both a very old topic and a hot new
topic like we've always known that there
was a relationship there but people are
really becoming more and more impressed
with how important that relationship is
but we haven't yet settled on the once
and for all cleanest clearest best way
of both explaining what that
relationship is and putting it to work
so this means both that sometimes we
miss the importance of information and
other times we exaggerate the importance
of information so
people will often say and i think i
probably said that you can use
information to do work what does that
mean so the typical example is you have
a piston on one side of the piston you
have some fuel you spark it it expands
and heats because of combustion and it
pushes the piston that's the standard
thing to do what richard is referring to
is the idea that if i have just one
particle inside a box and the particle's
moving around right so it has a lot of
velocity
but it's bouncing around in different
ways
if i don't know
where the particle is i can't do
anything with that there's no way if i
put a
divider in the box
half the time the divider will move to
the left half the time will move to the
right if i do that many many many times
it will do a random walk and that's not
doing a lot of work okay it's doing very
very little
whereas if i have the information of
knowing exactly where the particle is
and how it's moving then i can wait to
put the divider in at exactly the right
time so that i know the particle will
bump into the divider and move it in the
direction i want to move it okay so if i
know that for many many particles i can
do that many many times and coherently
add all of those pushes
because i had that extra information i'm
basically being maxwell's demon in this
case i'm extracting work from a high
entropy
uh set of particles because i have
information about it so people say look
in some sense information is doing the
work clearly it's not doing the work
what's doing the work is the particle
bumping into your divider but
information enables you to do that work
now if i were a little bit cynical i
would say look
information also enabled you to do the
work when you burn the fuel in the
regular piston because you knew the fuel
was in a low entropy state where you
could release some of that free energy
by sparking it okay so it's always
information in some sense that is
allowing you to do the manipulations
that extracts work from a physical
system and it's always the physical
system that is actually doing the work
but there is a
an interplay here knowing more
information lets you do more work lets
you do more interesting things that is
perfectly clear so what again we want to
be able to do is to say once and for all
what that relationship is in a clear
crisp way we're not quite there yet but
it's not wrong to say that knowing that
information is helping you do a little
bit of work
louis b says one of my favorite parts of
listening to you and other scientists is
the quickness and freeness with which
you will admit you don't know or we
don't know something i've even heard you
say we have lots of ideas but you don't
have high credence in any of them that
said are there some places eg many there
are some places eg many worlds where you
do seem to assign relatively high
credence i wonder what differentiates
these for you what about these ideas
capture you
well
there's that's complicated but there's
many things you know it's basically for
whatever sets of reasons i'm assigning
high credence because of some
combination of
priors and likelihoods and data that
comes in right so i have a high prior as
a scientist on a simple explanatory
theory that's one reason why many worlds
is one of my favorite theories but then
i will modify that credence based on the
data that comes in and i learn more
things about it so the only reason why
people switch from classical mechanics
to quantum mechanics was because they
were forced to do so by an overwhelming
amount of data
[Music]
and some things we just don't have the
data so you know my favorite example is
always dark matter i think we have very
good data that says there is dark matter
and we have very good data that tells us
certain properties of the dark matter
that it is cold there's a certain
density uh that has a certain
distribution through the universe we
have essentially no data
about what it is within that set of
properties you know many different kinds
of
particles you could imagine that would
be cold that would be dark etc so we
don't know whether it's axions or wimps
or something else so it makes perfect
sense to me to have high credence that
there is dark matter and low credence of
the dark matter is axions etc right
i don't think it's any more deep than
that um but
maybe what you're referring to is the
idea that that sometimes
um people do have very different
credences even when there's no data so
for let's still think about axions
versus wimps as dark matter candidates
um
for a long time wimps were the leading
candidate
to be the dark matter wimps being weakly
interacting massive particles and axions
were like the second leading candidate
and there were many many other
candidates but people didn't give equal
credence to every candidate they like
some better than others why do you do
that if the data do not distinguish well
the answer is that some of those
theories fit well with other ideas some
of those theories are more explanatory
than others so wimps are extremely
popular because they fit perfectly well
with many other ideas about physics
beyond the standard model supersymmetry
is an idea but extra dimensions strong
couplings there's a whole bunch of ideas
for physics beyond the standard model
that would naturally lead you to a
weakly interacting massive particle and
there's even what is called the wimp
miracle that if you ask if you have a
particle that was in thermal equilibrium
in the early universe and eventually it
stopped annihilating and sort of froze
in
what would the interaction strength have
to be for that to happen and roughly
speaking the answer is the weak
interactions of particle physics so that
was sort of a miracle that gave people
more credence that this theory was on
the right track so it fit in with other
ideas axions likewise were not predicted
they were not invented to be the dark
matter
axions are a hypothetical particle that
were invented i mean the original idea
came from peche and quinn roberto pache
and helen quinn when they were trying to
solve a problem in quantum field theory
called the strong cp problem cp is a
potential symmetry a particle physics
which unlike many times in particle
physics you think that there should be a
symmetry and you find that it's broken
in the case of cp what we found was that
the strong interactions should break it
but they don't that's not sort of the
opposite kind of problem and so pecha
and queen invented a mechanism that
explained uh how you could add one extra
field and you could explain why cp was
not broken by the strong interactions
and then both frank wilcheck former
mindscape guest and stephen weinberg
pointed out that the pechequin mechanism
predicted the uh existence of a new
particle and people were very optimistic
they would find the particle because it
was very easily findable they did not
find it so they did you know the next
sensible thing they expanded their
parameter space a little bit right and
they said well okay maybe let's be less
choosy about what symmetry breaking
scale is involved with this particle and
once they did that they realized oh if
we pick the symmetry breaking scale
appropriately we can get a dark matter
candidate and the axion could be the
dark matter and so that's a pretty good
dark matter candidate because it's a
particle that was invented for a
completely different reason but it's not
perfectly good because you have to like
make up this energy scale to fit the
data whereas with wimps the energy scale
just comes along for free but at least
it was not invented to be the dark
matter and other
candidates for dark matter were just
invented to be the dark matter right
they were not even trying to solve any
other problems so you see that there is
kind of a hierarchy of how the idea fits
in with other ideas and whether it's
solving problems or creating them and so
forth and these are all perfectly good
reasons to have high or low credence in
different ideas before the data come in
and decide the question once and for all
brian charlevoix says
first time question asker here and since
you want to write a book on democracy
i'm calling this a priority question
do you wish or hope for some form of
direct democracy to exist worldwide in
the next thousand or ten thousand years
uh no
i have zero hope for direct democracy to
exist ever
in any group of people more than like 20
people
because
as we talked about before you know
direct democracy is the idea that issues
that come up before the nation or the
state or whatever group of people you're
talking about every person votes on
every individual issue as opposed to
representative democracy where you vote
for a representative and the
representatives have the job of really
devoting their lives to understanding
these issues and deciding what to do
that latter system just seems much
better to me it's still democracy it's
still people voting and you know the
authority and the
uh authenticity what is the word i'm
looking for
um i don't know i'm losing the word but
the justification for the power being
held by these representatives is that
the people vote for them that's the
essence of democracy it's the people's
will that is uh giving government its
legitimacy and but representative
democracy is just infinitely more
sensible for
any system that is even a little bit
complicated and the modern world is
extremely extremely complicated so the
idea of ruling the world by direct
democracy seems uh crazy pants to me in
fact if you're interested you can go
back to the podcast i did with edward
watts about the fall of the roman
republic the roman republic fell and we
talked about why that happened but
first the question is
i mean not the question but the the
point that should be appreciated is the
roman republic lasted for 500 years
and was very very successful over those
500 years before it eventually collapsed
so that's a pretty good run and there is
a very clear
comparison to be done between the roman
republic and greek democracy because the
greeks were often
much more invested the athenians i
should say in direct democracy where you
would vote on everything and it led to
complete chaos because you know you
would vote to send out the naval fleet
then a week later you would vote to
bring it back and it was not a good way
to run a country and so the romans kind
of uh were much more successful because
they voted for representatives the
representatives did the work
representatives if they're good of
course you can always question whether
or not you're
having a system that elects good
representatives but if they're good they
will be much more able to understand the
complexities of the world and and guide
the country through them
humberto nani says may you please
comment about your favorite places on
the internet i'll go first all the nooks
of preposterousuniverse.com
so uh thank you umberto i don't i don't
really have a great answer to this i
just wanted to give roberto a chance to
advertise my website preposterous
universe.com so there are a lot of
things there are a lot of nooks and
crannies on on the website that you can
spend hours of fun
reading and watching videos and and
things like that but you know other
favorite places on the internet look my
internet use is not that sophisticated
in some sense i'm on the internet all
the time but i use it for email
i still use feedly to read blogs if
you're a long time listener you remember
neha narula one of the very first
podcasts i did talked about
cryptocurrency
and we talked about the different ways
that people use the internet and i said
that i still read blogs using a feed
reader and she was kind of shocked and
appalled that there are still people who
do that so i still do that um i'm on you
know twitter
youtube uh imager for just wasting my
time or reddit or whatever i
often lurk on the sixers subreddit much
more interesting than the physics
subreddits to me etc
but nothing nothing very profound i
don't have any special places that you
haven't heard of that i would go
recommending to be honest sorry
niccolo mousse messi says
regarding bayesianism you've often
argued that the potentially subjective
nature of priors is not an issue and i
agree with that but what about the fact
that often we can't list all possible
priors in the first place like for
example in theoretical physics this is
precisely the case since listing all
possible priors would imply coming up
with all the possible theories before
being able to update from evidence
doesn't this issue limit the application
of bayesianism to less speculative
settings
yeah i think this is a very important
issue i mean i wouldn't put it exactly
in the words that you put it in because
any good bayesian especially when you're
doing something like theoretical physics
and you're trying let's say you're
trying to explain the dark matter right
like we were just talking about you have
different credences on different
theories but you should put a certain
amount of credence on the set of
theories i haven't
explicitly listed the set of ideas i
haven't come up with yet right i mean
that's obviously always an open
possibility that's so that's easy to say
like that's not that's not the problem
there should be some credence on stuff
you haven't thought of yet that's easy
the problem is that the whole point of
bayesianism is that not only you have
those priors but then you update them
when new data comes in
and you update them on the basis of
these likelihood functions you say well
if this theory is right how likely is it
i would have gotten that data
that's easy to do when you have a theory
but that's very hard to do when you're
the proposition you're talking about is
i don't yet have a theory right in the
space of all theories i haven't yet
invented what is the chance i would see
this data that's really hard to uh
specifically say so i don't
you know in practice you can very often
get around this but
well you can think you get around it but
it's not perfectly clear at a principled
rigorous level that you're making sense
so we saw this at the very beginning of
this ama with aliens in the solar system
right you need to ask yourself
what is the likelihood that aliens in
the solar system would act in a certain
way and so you say you fool yourself
into thinking i have a theory called
aliens in the solar system but that
theory is not very specific what kind of
aliens how long have they been there are
they aggressive are they you know made
of biological materials you know there's
a million things that you haven't
answered and therefore it is difficult
to answer questions about what the
likelihoods are and i do think that that
is a an issue for bayesian reasoning and
i i'm sure people have debated it to
death to death in the depths of the
bayesian literature and i don't myself
really know what the answer is um i
would like to know more anyone out there
who has some ideas or knows some
literature about that that would be fun
to read
oleg ruvinsky says i am an israeli who
was born in ukraine so i've been
following the war very closely and it
made me reconsider what i thought about
the severity of our conflict in
comparison to the scale of what happens
in ukraine i wonder whether you had
similar thoughts about the severity of
u.s internal political conflict and the
threat it poses to u.s democracy in
comparison to the gradual slide over the
years of russia into totalitarianism
do you still think u.s democracy is
going through a severe existential
crisis
well yeah i do and but i mean this is a
good set of issues to be thinking about
for one thing
one correction i don't think there's any
gradual slide of russia into
totalitarianism the russia was part of
the soviet union was which was
totalitarian from the start okay i would
say that there was a brief moment when
maybe in some sense russia was trying to
be democratic okay
but there was never a time you know to
me that you know that your democracy is
working
when the ruling political party
tries to win but loses and hence over
power
and as far as i know that's never
happened in russia you know you have to
be able to lose and you have to be able
to hand over power when you lose in a
peaceful transition that's what really
makes you democracy not the voting part
okay
and so i think it's a very uh different
situation from the start comparing the
u.s to russia i mean there's no
one-to-one comparison they come from
very different historical trajectories
having said all that
the us uh is a much healthier democracy
right now is a very you know it's been
around a long time it has established
institutions
and
therefore it is not the same kind of
worry that you have in china or russia
or other places that have a totalitarian
history that doesn't mean there's no
worries though just that we just talked
about the fall of the roman republic it
lasted 500 years and then became an
empire
um a dictatorship right and the us could
do the same thing and
maybe every single year the chance is
small but there's an accumulated effect
and the effect you know the result of
losing democracy in the u.s is enormous
for not only the u.s but the world part
of why i worry about the us is because i
live here this is my country and so i
can i have some voice here in a way that
i think that other people should have
voices in their countries um
but also you know it's not just you say
there's some chance that democracy could
fail per year and it's small you say
well
how is this year different than last
year or 10 or 20 years ago
and i think that there are many many
objectively true facts about the current
situation that make it clear that
democracy is more fragile right now than
it used to be you know i just said that
the real test of democracy is a peaceful
transfer of power and we just had a
major political party that tried not to
hand over power and rather than those
people being thrown in jail they're
still in the government they're still
trying to be a ruling political party
and we're trying to treat it as business
as usual right you know just politics
people disagree with each other blah
blah blah i don't think it is business
as usual i think it is a true
undermining of legitimacy of democracy
and even though it's not nearly as bad
uh the democrats have another problem
with democracy namely that they look at
what republicans are doing and they
cease to think of republicans as
partners in the democratic project they
think that they're not really legitimate
people in the system anymore and the
whole point of democracy is you have to
work with the people you don't agree
with and i think that's breaking down
and that breakdown of the ability to
work with the people you don't agree
with might ultimately be much more
important to the failure of democracy in
the us than any one politician's
attempts to seize power or
change their vote outcomes or anything
like that you need buy-in you can only
have a successful democracy if everyone
in the country wants to be in a
successful democracy and i think that is
evaporating the united states that's a
huge crisis and i can't say too much
about what a big problem that is in my
view tomas sedovich says are there plans
for audiobook versions of the biggest
ideas books i've thoroughly enjoyed the
previous ones but the equations would
likely make that difficult could this be
solved by a supplemental pdf or
something similar
there will be audiobook versions yes uh
i'm not exactly sure how we're going to
solve the obvious problems here um there
usually are
pdf supplements for figures
in books there's many more figures in
the biggest ideas books than there were
in previous books because it's more you
know i have a lot of graphs and things
like that as well as the ordinary you
know illustrations
so um
what i tentatively think is that there
will be an audio book and i will narrate
it but it won't be an exact translation
in other words when i did my other audio
books they're very fussy the producers
of the audiobooks you need to say
exactly every word no more or no less
than what was in the book
i can easily read the equation out loud
that i can do no problem
but figures are a little bit harder and
sometimes the meaningfulness of the
equation is a little bit less clear if
you can't stare at it with your eyeballs
so what i would like to do
is negotiate an ability to improvise a
little bit while reading the book and be
a little bit more wordy and explanatory
about what's going on in the figures and
the equations rather than just reading
it word for word i have no idea whether
the you know i don't make the audio book
i read it but there's a company that
produces and sells them and so i have to
see what they think i will i will try to
do that but we'll have to see
like so there can't be really a
supplemental pdf with equations because
that would just be the book that would
just be buy the book which i encourage
you to do the heart the hard copy of the
book even if you get the audio book i
still encourage you to get a hard copy
exactly because
these are deep difficult ideas and
you're going to want to look back at the
at the paper and say oh yes i see i mean
either hard copy or you know ebook
version that that's that's okay there
will definitely be an ebook version and
again we'll try our best to make sure
the ebook version has the equations
presented correctly etc but when i say
we
it's not me people always come to me and
like you know this equation was typeset
badly in your book like i don't do that
they don't even ask my input about that
uh so you have to talk to the company
that makes the books
okay i'm going to
group two questions together one is from
phil who says do you think there's value
in making the basic math of physical
theories more constructive computational
right now a lot of it builds on things
like the real numbers their whole
existence is not proven constructively
and only an infinitesimal fraction of
them are computable this seems like a
bit shaky as a foundation
and then rollo burgess says this is a
question i've been thinking about since
coming across an observation in scott
aronson's book quantum computing since
democritus
basically mathematically the set of
computable numbers is a subset of the
reals of measure zero this means that if
the universe is continuous almost none
of its states can ever precisely be
calculated using any set of physical
laws the laws must be continuous but our
calculation procedures can only yield
computable answers aronson thinks this
point makes it seem likely the universe
isn't truly continuous in a mathematical
sense do you think this kind of point is
potentially sound or flawed in some way
and is the latter why
well i don't know so both questions are
asking you know are our difficulties of
various forms in coping with
the continuum the real numbers right
that particular uncountable infinity of
numbers that we have in the real numbers
every
theory of physics that is very
successful right now
is based on continuum numbers quantum
mechanics classical mechanics relativity
whatever you want quantum field theory
etc real numbers or complex numbers or
the equivalents vector spaces manifolds
these all are smooth continuous things
there are problems both conceptually and
uh in the foundations of math with
dealing with these things and therefore
it's very natural to wonder you know
maybe nature doesn't actually use that
maybe it's just that we approximate it
that way
because there's some discreetness or
granu granularity or something like that
but it's too small for us to see
so
i don't know i don't have strong
feelings about this you know i think
that
one thing that i would emphasize is that
our difficulties don't matter to the
world you know our difficulties in
calculating
some state that the universe is in or
our
difficulties in
understanding the definition of the
continuum or the continuum hypothesis
etc nature doesn't care about any of
these things so the only motivation for
me would be is if you could really show
that continuous theories were just
incoherent right were just impossible if
they're possible then nature can do it
and maybe that's true i don't know one
way or the other it certainly would be
easier in a lot of ways if nature were
not continuous and by the way
one thing to emphasize very strongly
here is that the opposite of continuous
is not living on some kind of lattice
okay the simplest way to take the world
and make it discreet is to literally
take the smooth space time around us and
and map it onto a set of points a
lattice of points in space and time
there's very good reason to think that
that is not how the universe works
there's no like length scale like the
planck length
with little bits connected point by
point quantum mechanics just doesn't
work that way and certainly holography
and black hole information etc do not
work that way
but
there still could be some kind of
discrete countable structure underlying
everything so i'm very open to people
who think that
but it's a challenge because quantum
mechanics isn't that the schrodinger
equation is defined on a vector space
which involves smooth evolution so you
are you would you're potentially
changing quantum mechanics and i do have
ideas about this by the way but let's be
honest there is no empirical motivation
there's no data that says we should
change quantum mechanics right now
andrew harris asks a priority question
isaac newton was no doubt a very clever
intellect if you could magically revive
him and he was your student how long do
you think it would take him to get up to
speed with current day physics what
would be the main obstacles you as his
tutor face in accomplishing this task
uh yeah einstein or einstein i said
newton he was very smart he invented
calculus so he would be fine i think in
the modern world it would absolutely
take him time to come up to speed you
know roughly speaking if he just did the
dumbest thing in the world and said
given newton's knowledge of the world
how would he correspond to a modern day
physics student
and roughly it's some kind of first-year
undergraduate right because first-year
undergraduates learn
newtonian mechanics and calculus and he
invented those things
now admittedly we have slightly better
notation and we have slightly better um
concepts like he'd never talk about
energy for example that was not a
something that he understood very well
certainly didn't talk about vectors
that's something they didn't know about
at all
but by the second half of your first
year student studies as a physics
student you're learning about
electromagnetism which you certainly
didn't know about and in your second
year
you're onto relativity and quantum
mechanics and things like that so
roughly speaking he's a first year
undergrad uh give him three years to
catch up on the undergrad
stuff two more years in grad school and
he's a working modern physicist but i
suspect that he's a better than average
working modern physicist so let's give
him four years overall three or four
years to catch up if you really devoted
yourself to doing nothing but learning
physics which maybe newton would do make
it one or two years but it's something
like that something roughly he was very
very smart but he was not superhuman you
know he was not an alien and he needs to
learn the notation and do the problem
sets just like everybody else
uh i i don't think there be any deep
conceptual
issues he would have to unlearn some
um
cherished beliefs that people had in the
1600s about the nature of reality but i
mean that was what made him very good is
i bet he could relearn that stuff pretty
quickly
krather luca says how do you believe a
person should weigh their feelings
versus rationality in decision making
emotions are usually so random and
unreliable yet a life trying to avoid
passion barely seems like a life worth
living so i don't think that there is
any weighing between
feelings versus rationality i think they
do two totally different things um it's
like saying
which is more important in driving a car
um
pushing down the gas pedal or turning on
the ignition key you need to do both
likewise your feelings and you know
david hume was very clear about this
reason is and always should be the slave
of the passions what he meant was
passions tell us what we want
reason tells us how to get it those are
compatible operations those are not
incompatible operations
i think it's a mistake to say that you
know
acting passionately and emotionally is
somehow the opposite of acting
rationally
you can let some subset of your passions
override your rationality and get in
trouble that way and find out that
ultimately your passions are being
undermined because you are not rational
enough so my philosophy is absolutely
100
that what you should do is not weigh one
versus the other but let your emotions
and your cognition work together rather
than work against each other
cooper says the question why is there
something rather than nothing appears to
presuppose that nothing is a more
natural state than something and thus
the presence of something demands
explanation
i'm not sure why that should be as the
concept of true nothingness is difficult
for me to philosophically wrap my head
around do you have any thoughts on the
matter
yes i have thoughts you can read them on
the internet you can google why is there
something rather than nothing
and my name and you will find a paper
that i wrote with exactly that title
it appears in some rutledge companion
book
you know
major i forget the name of the book but
it's like you know current controversies
in physics or the rutledge companion to
the philosophy of science or something
like that it was an invited chapter and
i wrote about why is there something
rather than nothing and you're right the
the language steers us a little bit
wrong
i wouldn't say that asking why is there
something rather nothing necessarily
presupposes that nothing is more natural
state i mean maybe there is no natural
state but there are alternatives you
know there could have been something or
there could have been nothing and maybe
there's some reason why but honestly
what i ultimately come down to say is
there probably isn't a reason why there
is something rather than nothing because
there isn't really such an alternative
uh what does it mean to say there could
have been nothing
nothing is not something that can be
nothing is not a state of existence it
is stated that nothing exists right um
so i think that the most likely thing is
that this is not a question that is has
some answer that it will satisfy
everyone it's just a question we are
tricked into asking because of the way
that we talk not because of the way the
explanatory matrix of the universe is
actually arranged
okay the very last question for this ama
comes from emmett francis who says have
you thought about doing a live mindscape
episode perhaps a zoom session that
patrons could attend and submit
questions to the chat it could be a fun
experiment and a good way to get
together with this highly diverse group
of minescrape patrons i'm sure some of
us would be willing to help facilitate
if that would be of interest
you know
i've thought about lots of things
including things like that i've thought
about you know having a live event with
former guests i've thought about
bringing old guests back on to you know
talk to each other rather than just talk
to me i've talked about having a live
call an event like you're talking about
and there's two things that prevent me
from doing it right now number one it
seems like work
even if the actual event doesn't work
you have to put a lot of thought into
how to do it right and that's work and
there's lots of ways to do it wrong
so it does require some thought and some
arrangement and the other is like i
haven't really thought of
any particular
way of doing something very different
than what i'm doing now
that would be better or even
good in a different way compared to what
i'm doing now i mean we have certain
goals in i have certain goals with the
mindscape podcast your mileage may vary
but you know i want to
get to people's ideas i want to be able
to interrogate them and and increase our
understanding of them ideas that are a
little bit subtle and systematic and
require some
time to dig out and explain and think
about the consequences of
the amas what we're doing right here
this is a perfect kind of off-the-cuff
thing i don't do planning for the amas
um so i can be sloppy and say i don't
know you know that that's perfectly fine
in ama land
but a live thing is just a different
thing it's not systematic uh it's from
there will be very good questions and
some not so good questions um some
questions will be more interesting to
others etc etc so i don't know how to do
that in a way that would be
clearly better than what is going on
right now so maybe i could i will keep
thinking about it i'm very happy to get
you know
keep suggesting things like that i'm not
i don't want to dissuade people uh even
though i haven't done anything radical
like that i'm still very open to the
possibilities so who knows that's the
great thing about having your own
podcast i can do whatever i want i could
make it all me talking to my cats from
now on maybe that would double my
listenership i don't know but uh the
cats don't tend to talk back unless i
just literally put them in their little
cat carriers
and then they'd be making noises but it
would not be talking to me in a
comprehensible way so it's not really in
the spirit of the podcast per se that's
how we are that's where we are right now
hope you're enjoying the podcast as it
is and i'll see you next month bye
[Music]
you